[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
yo
round
[Music]
[Music]
good to see y'all up here early on a
sunday
doing what we do for the realm
let's talk to the people
cheryl mack what's going on
the legendary general mac the og of the
building salute
zach riley what's going on
yeah you messy i see that
christopher heart what's up lydia master
what's going on
far q that sir the brightest sun
the brightest
what's going on only on xbox what's up
now live 210 what's up let me know
what's going on yes we do have the
legendary brad sands will be in the
realm today talking to the people i
sound low all right all right
make sure my levels is right
get a little closer gotta get a little
close still rain in the building let me
split screen salute appreciate you you
know
we are talking we are talking right now
yeah i think what's going on what's up i
think what it is oh hold on my man black
conflict x let's go
yeah i think the music a little luck my
levels seem the same that they normally
be but i will keep checking on it during
the show appreciate you still ringing
ko3 black truth what's up
i'm max is going on pop not popped out
it's my man
you know he's not the first the second
pop not pop not two
years
dave
what's going on good to see y'all up in
here early atomic what's going on
so yeah we will have the legendary
brad seb's got a lot of juicy topics you
know king gonna be ready there's some
topics there for him you can guess what
his topic is
but anyway gorilla one what's going on
what's going on i see you and and and
triple n in the building salute so yeah
we're gonna get him up in here and um
have some fun i'll leave y'all with the
bars of dallas man
and uh yeah we'll be right back get
ready
everybody's lined up with full strength
we outside for sure for sure for sure
all right come back let me get brad up
in here
[Music]
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be keeping these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say i'm better
than money because you can bank on me
being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
[Music]
you could say that i'm very spoiled for
them to be a dog thing very loyal but i
ain't gonna hold you i ain't here to boy
you you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you i've always been a
nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tiller uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
[Music]
to say it i'm embarrassed for you i've
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be keeping these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the
[Applause]
when i'm in the range i was the hardest
to start regardless back we was
messaging people on
[Music]
i'm very spoiled for them to be your dog
thing very loyal but i ain't gonna hold
you i ain't here to boil you you ain't
gotta say it i'm embarrassed for you
i've always been a nerd never been a
loser making voltron with a gang of
cougars and i'm going places better tell
her uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep
on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look you gotta mess up and turn me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't wanna be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that
this is that yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
messaging people on aim
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
for you i've always been a nerd never
been a loser making voltron with a gang
of cougars and i'm going places better
tell her uber cause it's pretty hard to
sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing that
real but coming to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i be eating
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that
this is that yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rains
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
um
[Music]
but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here
to boy you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you i always been a nerd
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all missed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i'm
addicted to flipping the sample and
making
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
to be your dog thing very loyal but i
ain't gonna hold you i ain't here to boy
you ain't gotta say it i'm embarrassed
for you always been a nerd never been a
loser making voltron with a gang of
cougars and i'm going places better tell
her uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep
on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is the yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal i got it
[Music]
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
keeping these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on the song with me that's
understandable i kill a beat and they
want to compare me to freddie and jason
i'd rather be hannibal they'd be like
why use a video game just be original
y'all so dramatical i know it's random
but i'm addicted to flipping the sample
and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to started regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't heard a boy you ain't gotta say it
i'm embarrassed for you i always been a
nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell an uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
and we are
live
iron lord podcast
lord cognito here talking about the
latest with advanced gg there's a lot of
things going on with the new product
line let's get right to it
so we got that focus line this is that
standard this is what we use right now
kind of our caffeine substitute and what
we usually do right now when we're
gaming we don't use coffee anymore we're
utilizing its focus on deck number two
you already know it's my favorite right
here the energy line you already know
birthday cake one of my absolute
favorites completely delicious this is a
pre-workout equivalent and also doesn't
use beta adeline so you don't get the
jitters and stuff like that so it's
really good for that and then the new
new we got that hydration line y'all
this is really good for people who don't
like caffeine who want an electrolyte
substitute and it is really sugar-free
absolutely delicious so you got your
three choices once again you know car
glove is sour you already know and we're
doing this right now so go get yourself
to advanced gg.com use code iron lord on
the checkout this is something i use all
the time gotta support advanced gg great
products if you want to get your workout
on even if you don't work out you're
just gaming you need that focus and
again the hydration line for those who
don't want caffeine no sugar
electrolytes you're good to go lord
cognito here iron lord podcast
peace
[Music]
a proclamation
[Music]
i'ma just chill and watch them any
snacks in the attic i wanted to chill
with the pack and be like a young wolf
but then they would mistake me for
addict if i can imagine it's cool to
give you some advice and invite your
girl to your squadron cause if you don't
give her that option you're gonna be
single player like siren you're gonna
get tossed in the bushes by king david
royalty and not a pretender detrimental
to an elemental what's an avatar to a
knee bender i gotta be me though
that's cool but i got bad news even if
you really was that jew king david still
be the king of the statues since the
juvenile i've been cursed with a curse
to be musical and if you hate it we'll
meet in the crucible wasn't it nothing
it's cool and it's beautiful we let you
know that your dreams are pursued but
whatever you want to do then it's doable
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the lord's day
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on a lord's day
[Music]
all right bike check mic check and all
that good stuff let me see some levels
talk to me real quick so i just want to
make sure we're good hello yeah there we
go how's my beard
[Laughter]
welcome to the ireland's podcast llc and
also live on lords of gaming.net episode
number 269. that's another glorious
sunday we're back at the round table on
the lord's date i'm extremely excited
about our special guest and we've got
star doc software
multiple embracer group acquisitions
death stranding to game pass
and playstation pc launches to discuss
so we're going to get right into it
i want to introduce a lord who not only
has his finger on the pulse of windows
software and tech enthusiast culture but
is highly respected as a multifaceted
journalist with a cool touch of
insightful sarcasm
introducing
the vice president and general manager
of star doc software plus editorial
advisor to the bww media group
the lord of usbc cables
master of business administration
who always reminds us to read beneath
the surface and that more bs is always
welcome
live from cincinnati and kind enough to
make his debut at the realm of the lords
my man
lord brad sands how we doing sir that is
without a doubt the best intro i've ever
received including my own wedding
[Laughter]
you oh lord and your realm is absolute
honor to have you huge fan of what you
do first of all how you been and have
you got a chance to be playing any game
sir just quickly yeah you know i mean
just one i you guys put i was watching
i've seen obviously your podcast before
but you guys have by far the best
graphics
i've been on
just like the the intro podcasting like
the effort that goes into it is always
awesome and it's not something you guys
just threw together and i always i
always love that i appreciate it
i appreciate that no seriously it means
a lot coming from coming from our peers
and and the work that we all do because
i know what type of work it goes into
this like this stuff like people think
man all you do is you just show up and
you just turn on the zoom and like it
rolls like no no no no it's it's a grind
some days a lot of days and so man it's
all good like i'm happy to be here
excited to be here
we are like steamrolling into what i
usually consider a lot of people like e3
is the best time of the gaming year and
it's like no like i'm a i'm a big fan of
the fall like because that's when the
rubber beats the road we're starting to
see like deadlines coming up and like
games and theories should be launching
and so like
embrace like this is just like entering
uh insanity time and i love this time of
the year no we're gonna be extremely
happy this time of the year extremely
disappointing
but it's really a lot of stuff is going
off but uh we gotta get it
i think it really just depends on your
viewpoint like from a from like a
podcaster and content perspective like
it's it doesn't matter like if it's
really good stuff like hey you got stuff
to talk about like if things get delayed
well you still got stuff don't talk
about it
yeah no good point we had a lot of stuff
to talk about regardless of delay
for sure we will get into it they said
uh brad is a little low they want you
turn up just a little bit brad they want
to hear that the melodious voice just
see if i move it a little closer if that
helps out yeah just a little logs they
love to hear you so that's what's up but
while we do that we still got the four
horsemen of gaming those original lords
of the rubber here at the round table
with those time sensitive intros king
kids that's right
[Laughter]
the difficult game conqueror lord of his
own world and the heart of the young
wolf my man lord addict of the attic
show how we doing sir
doing pretty good uh you know we only
got brad for an hour so that's that's my
intro today my man
and of course we have the most technical
gaming lord the solo gamer who lives
with the single player selfish
experience and also the sastradamus and
lord clarity of the iron bank how are we
doing sir doing good doing fantastic
glad to have brad here um yeah i've been
playing uh cursed golf which is really
fun oh shout out to the guys over at the
doomsayers network i was on there on
friday on the slayers then podcast
podcast appearances
outside right right you got a quote
under the knife right before oh yeah
that's right
so shout out to the happy wise old gamer
the wizard gamer was he was reserved he
wasn't really i was exp he was behaved
and i wow expecting that
one time one time with the guys over
there
and that's it and of course we have the
incredible hulk of this aka the access
gamer oh the prophet of xbox swami king
of the statues who demands nothing less
than that premium experience it is the
leader of the fraud alert movement oh
and the general of the stop snitching
as the stop stitching to the regulators
of brazil movement
okay how are we doing sir i am doing
fantastic uh i'm gonna give a shout out
to aj and usyk yesterday um anthony
it joshua a fantastic fight
yesterday couldn't do combat talk
yesterday because real things in in life
happens
at a friend of mine that had to uh get
to uh a center for help mental health
and an addiction
and
that was more than anything
so i had to make sure that they they got
to the facility because you know we have
to reach out we have to help everyone i
mean if they're screaming out for help
then absolutely absolutely as much as
you possibly can so the fight happened
happened early in the daytime me and aj
was talking in the background it was
just a
ongoing free-flowing thing
that was trying to get to happen but it
didn't happen but the fight happened and
those gay guys gave a great account of
the ability of the self listen
two guys going to ring
more than likely one guy is going to
come out the winner of course but you
both won when you're stepped into those
ropes so he's not a loser uh you know
you have to give effort and he lives to
fight another day so that's fantastic
right now what i'm playing
fortnight fortnite got me crazy oh
fortnight got dragon ball z hold on and
i'm coming coming high and everybody
kamehameha is for the world and i i run
and i get these commandments and i'm
flying on clouds and i love what
uh fortnite is doing and i see they got
destiny coming up next destiny's up next
um
and also playing coal to the lamb
all right this
is an evil
it is my most evil addiction that i have
right now converting people then going
and preaching the world
and then again
you like how you levitate never take
your mind
opens up and you're like
also please you guys go to games on
daily for yesterday's show and watch
attic on yesterday's show and games on
i want to see my man on more shows i
agree right so you guys out here stop
reaching out for me and reach out for
him yeah exactly um but that's it's off
we saw salsa i don't know
they reach out yeah they reach out i
just have to humbly uh decline decline
because you're scheduled i'll be the
same
soon soon though things will change for
me soon yeah but anyway and of course we
have the gaming ninja himself the
shinobi lord cognito spread that
willingness and ramana ilp not telling
what you want to hear but what you need
to hear shout out to mr maddie player
shout out to fire duke had a good one
talking about gamescom talking about
quake call i'm talking about the disney
marvel or potential um game showcase
also we had uh um the final duke
ultimate where me and maddie uh talked
about ellis and patreon kind of the
after effects of 2022 all the delays go
check that out what's left to be excited
for
go check that out did the new game get
delayed a lot of new games like it was
slated to come out something was hot
yeah
a lot of new games you got the midnight
sun you got the um high on life things
yeah we got that so shout out to my
life's supposedly still coming this year
yeah still coming this year
i mean just delays happening i'm just
you know pointing it out there oh oh
okay what you're doing
okay anyway so oh yeah our last shot the
last word shout out to bob's tiger
trainer had the legendary professor bro
man it's one of the inspirations in the
community charitable guy does gcx if it
wasn't for him last last word would not
exist because i would have met ebon if i
was i didn't go to florida for that
convention and uh solve let's do the
super chats real quick set the rules of
engagement to respect branstad yeah so
i'm going to read this first bunch of
super chats and then we're going to
leave all the rest for the end of the
show because brad is on limited time so
we definitely want to make sure we get
through our interview with him so let me
get into these super chats
donald tackle five dollars can't believe
we got some bs in my favorite xbox five
bs aka brad sam my favorite xbox we
gotta give propagation let's get context
the context here
then we got gerald mack two dollar super
chat the lord's on some real bs today
i see what they're doing
is this something you experience often
brad
oh yeah
he said oh yeah he said then we have
necromancer five dollar super chat with
this topic lineup why does it seem like
there was a coup d'etat attempt on the
king and those other guys podcasts
hustle and motivate members for 19
months fire fire fire fire it's
super chat salute to the lords has ilp
been acquired by embracer yet for an
undisclosed amount welcome to the real
brad i appreciate thank you sir
we cannot confirm or deny it
i hope microsoft uh steps in steps
the offer is really enticing
i'm ready i'm ready to be warmly
embraced
i want to wear green
please imagine imagine if sony came to
us with the belt
i always said that right
our intro would be us galloping in on
horses
you better take that bad king
he will not tell me that i can just i
could just hear phil now i'm going to
try man i'm going to try call you back
right here last last super chat dj berto
dust 2 dollars
the only bs in iop is the man himself
brad said yes sir
all right super chat we got almost four
hundred dollars like 100 likes what's
that like hit that like button share it
out bro
drop some knowledge exactly so that we
got into what the lords have been
playing we got to focus on lord brad
sam's his video game system history his
journey into business consulting and
editorial strategy and of course what
led him to creating the amazing youtube
channel and becoming a vp of star doc
software so lord brad let's start from
the very beginning what was some of the
first video game systems you had and
what got you into gaming
oh well it even starts i think prior to
video games i mean apple ii like that
i'm old enough not i'm not super old but
i'm old enough that that's what i grew
up with like that was in the house yes
and i think the first console that we
actually i know the first console was
the classic nintendo eight bit yeah and
then we went from eight bit to we never
had a super nintendo i missed out on
that but we did have a genesis so we
went from 8-bit because then we went to
the house of sonic
and then back to nintendo 64.
and then the og you know as soon as xbox
launched the directx boxes they called
it back in the day
no joke walked into a blockbuster and
bought my first xbox at blockbuster and
rented halo because i didn't have enough
money
so so the xbox was the first acquire
with your cash
yes yeah that's when i was old enough to
actually be able to buy or like had
money like disposable income to be able
to buy a console how did it how did it
feel with your brand because before you
was dictated to right so right now
you're doing the dictating this is your
cash you're walking in
did you was it other consoles there but
you had your mind trained you was fixing
uh i knew that was happening so
i knew that i wanted an xbox like i knew
that before because
for reasons i can never logically
explain i guess maybe windows 95 like
i've always been a microsoft enthusiast
like soon as i got my hands on 95 like
one of the first times i remember my dad
like really yelling at me like really
getting into me was when he was away at
work and i upgraded the family pc from
98 to me oh windows mbe
yeah remember me
millennium millennium editions yes and
that's why my dad came when he said you
did what
yeah and me had a lot of problems yeah
compared to 98 yeah exactly it was it
was not a smart move like
i legitimately did it because i like the
icons and me yeah the account was nice
the ui the visual it didn't look kind of
appealing i admit
microsoft was coming out with a gaming
console like that's it like that's
that's what i want because you know at
that point i was a kid i like playing pc
games and i was like well if they're
building a console like it's microsoft
it's got to be great and as it turns out
it was
shout out to you man really really cool
just wanted to know if he had any
standout titles from the edius days and
then obviously the the og oh man so
from the nes days and this goes way back
there were two games that we i mean i
played through all the marios like that
was it but the the two that we played in
our house a ton because the two older
brothers were little league world series
and tecmo super bowl oh of course
those two games played a ton so much so
that there was an exploit in tecmo super
bowl that if you played as the 49ers and
you were ronnie lott roddy lap
and you ran out of bounds on the
sidelines you could run faster than any
player in the game
jackson days oh man the terrorizing that
game used to call the hot dog
[Laughter]
hold him with the offensive line that
forever holds
great game so then you get to the i get
the xbox your first one you got that
interest for microsoft console and then
what were i i obviously rented halo
which we yeah halo ended up becoming a
purchase for sure
uh project gotham racing was out around
that time like those were the two i
think that i played for a while because
like if the friends were over it's like
we're playing halo if like i'm playing
by myself like project gotham racing
uh that that held me over for a long
time i think those two titles there was
i'm sure a madden tossed in there as
well but when you say like what you know
what did you play original in xbox oh
and then the uh what else the old flying
shooting game that they crimson's guys
crimson skies yes yes
salute yeah man were you ripping music
to your hard drive brad
[Laughter]
i mean there was definitely a point in
my life where i was in the
soldering game of opening up those oh
you would solve share similar histories
a career pattern idea what you're
talking about career paths
wow it's so interesting to hear that
sometimes the xbox needed you know to be
repaired
exactly exactly
so good too you guys were so good at
your jobs you repaired it that's so much
extra stuff
yeah it was really an amazing college i
mean at the end of the day i think kind
of kind of similar to you i think my my
initial reaction was okay i just was
making a console i don't know how i feel
about that but then when you actually
you start to learn about it in the specs
i think the thing that attracted me as a
techie was hard drive in the console you
know i mean you know xbox live becomes
the thing
and even before before that uh i
remember halo just system link was just
mind-blowing it's all right system link
yeah yeah like it would i became like a
mock network engineer and i'm getting
little cat cables removing being king
and moving them around the house and
song and getting extra tvs we're just so
mesmerized to have that aspect with halo
in the thing so then from there you just
kind of you stay throughout the xbox
ecosystem do you do um i'm gonna say you
obviously the next progression is uh 360
and just keep on at that point yeah so i
owned every single xbox like
the one the 360 like the uh the xbox one
the one x and uh an s and
no playstation in here at all i did have
a playstation 4 for a while
and then it just
like
after college and all that like my
friend group was just on xbox and it was
like
and
you know the games we play that i play
socially i should say are primarily call
of duty yeah like that's like that's the
the kind of glue that kept a bunch of us
together and so like
xbox like how many is in your group like
uh
there's
a handful like five or six guys five or
six in the group that we play with
weekly and then there's probably like
you could maybe double that and that's
like on like a monthly or like quarterly
basis and so cool uh like when co when
warzone war zone is what we play the
most these days and so when war zone 2
drops i can guarantee you you know a
bunch of people are going to come
flocking back yeah oh my god so when you
heard the news about activision yeah
that had to hit
but it's so true though like
if there's a like i like xbox and it's
like they're gonna go buy my favorite
game i'm like well because right now
playstation has like the drop on
multiplayer maps and some other stuff
yes and so like seeing it come over to
the green side it's like you know here
we go there we go it's a good point and
it's funny because in the 360 era
obviously them having the marketing
rights and
the controller and being kind of like an
fps kind of centric console it grabbed
its identity i remember call of duty
when modern warfare came out that's the
only time i betrayed halo and i was just
like man this thing's sick i i didn't
realize it was 60 fps at the time now
looking back and i'm like oh that's why
this thing was mesmerizing to me and
also the point of like i said your
favorite developer your favorite studio
shout out to mr maddie plays you know
he's a but that's the guy through and
through so when that deal went through
he's just like man like these i'm i love
western rpgs like it makes complete
sense for me to be in that ecosystem
even more so i understand your point on
call of duty so i wanted to talk about
you know like kind of the career path
you know sure as far as like now
business consulting and kind of the
attraction to the field like what led
you to that and wanting to get your mba
and all that stuff yeah so it's a it's a
kind of crazy path um but if any like
whose path isn't like odd because
there's there's no like linear path so
the real short version of it is
graduated from undergrad with an
accounting degree went into and joined a
company
uh they lasted about two years the whole
it was a public company they collapsed
like literally
collapsed they couldn't pay their bills
and so
uh as we got laid off another company
came in to take over our job and i had
to train the people and they said why
don't you just come work for us i was
like okay
and so i did that for a couple years
realized i hated consulting like that
was
just not my jam and so at that point i
was like i'm gonna go back and get my
mba because my wife worked at a
university or still works there and she
had her master's and i'm super
competitive and she's like oh
it was it was a little wifey okay
nba so i'm getting my mba and while i'm
getting my mba i'm writing for a website
called neowin which they're primarily
microsoft they do gaming but they're
microsoft uh microsoft website
and i'm going through my mba and i come
up with an idea for a company and i want
to run with it and this is how this all
came about and i was like hey i'm going
to have to stop doing neon i'm going to
chase this company that i want to build
it's just big data tracking stock market
stuff and so
i reached out to the owner of neon or
one of the owners and i said look i'm
you know i need to step back like this
is it and they got and i'm not even
joking this he said
if you don't step back i'll give you
your angel investment to run with this
company oh
and so the company was called tracker
okay and ran for that for three years
doing writing and journalism for neoin
while doing this and that company the
tracker did really well we and then we
got crushed we were going to raise some
money other companies raised a whole
bunch more we couldn't compete
long story short that company dies i
step away from neon because i met
another guy in a bar in new york city
new york
and he's like hey i just bought a media
company can you come help me run it and
i was like okay and so i did that for
and that was bww media group
so i did that for five six years okay
and last summer microsoft announced
windows 11 right
and the ceo of stardock was one of the
other owners of neowin okay and stardock
makes software that customizes windows
and his name is brad wardell
i mean i've known him since brad and
brad yeah
i've known him for more than a decade or
15 years something like that point and
he just messaged me he's like look
windows 11 is coming out i need help
running the window side of my business
can you come help me do that and i was
like yeah like you know now i get to do
what i get to love like
i still you know i still get to do my
podcasting i still get to talk about
xbox and then as a as a career i'm
working on software that customizes the
os that you know got me started in all
this nice and so that's the
the there's a lot of note there's a lot
i know there's a lot no it's an
interesting path that's what you said
because like you said you had that you
know business consulting you go to the
nba thing and then it's like this
journalistic path obviously the rod
ptree.com where i know before and then
now you go full circle kind of almost
back to where you really want to be
which is you know kind of like the the
software the customization the
personalization of os and things of that
nature um what i wanted to ask you about
was just um
content creation in general where like
when did the serious youtube because
that's what i kind of came across your
content obviously throughout i would see
a couple articles here and there but um
you know i would see like who is this
guy you know cool background
always having fun like what made you
indulge into the wild wild west of
youtube youtube was sort of a
at the time it was a necessary evil sort
of thing
because it started back oh god i would
like 2013 2014 like that so i've done a
podcast it's a solo podcast it's almost
like a monologue every friday just about
every friday since that time and i
started out as audio only this was on
neowin.net and people said like hey we
want we want this on youtube and i'm
like i don't want to be on video like i
don't even like combing my hair
so what it was it was just the audio
version and i just put like a graphic up
just on youtube and what like every
other content creator learned is like
hey like discoverability on youtube is
actually way better than google and
other places and so it's slowly morphed
in from a just doing a podcast on friday
to
do like hey xbox news dropped like xbox
content just really caught fire at least
for me on
youtube and so that was just like the
slow sort of churn from okay it's just a
graphic to me sitting in front of what
is now yes behind me yes no it's like
brother i remember you know coming
across your content and it's extremely
informative very analytical you know you
kind of keep things fair and one thing i
respect like
i remember like seeing like a lot of
surface with those surface videos for
you that really took off and i was just
like man this is impressive like because
what i like is you give both sides you
give the window side of what's going on
in microsoft ecosystem
general tech news and then you got the
xbox because the xbox guy's like we got
to confirm if brad said it's a goal it's
a girl
[Laughter]
so i thought that was a cool very
marriage of content and then also
quickly you're an author of a book tell
us about that book sir
yeah so the book was
i am uh crazy and
in some regards and so i'm i listen to a
ton of music and i'm not even joking
this is how it came out so there's a
darius rucker song and he said when was
the last time you did something for the
first time and i was like man it was
good and i was like that's kind of crazy
and so i was taking a shower and so my
journalism career got started with
microsoft surface
like i shouldn't say got started but
like blew up yes my first big scoops in
the industry were surface 2 or surface
yeah the surface 2. that whole lineup
like i leaked it out and had tons of
info and so i've been following the
surface brand from
its very first day you know even prior
to launching all the way up through
today like even right now like this is a
surface book 3. there's a surface pro 8
like i'm just a fan of the brand
and i felt like i could tell a story and
had the contacts to actually say like
what actually happened how did microsoft
birth a billion dollar product line and
so i just started pinging everybody that
i know that ever worked on it and enough
of them came back and said yeah i'll
talk to you obviously off the record
because some of them still work there
and so i just dude i wrote that book
from
in less than a year like eight months i
just every every night i was writing you
know a chapter and shipping it off to it
to paul who helped edit it and like it
was a grind
but that's like my insanity of like if
i'm going to do something i just i i do
it i'm in and i'm here
that's that's right
i respect it i respect it no that's
that's cool and you it's very
introspective because you see
how like i said the the the rough start
the failure to what it became like it
was not easy and it's interesting you
know say to see the parallel sometimes
also with xbox a little bit in my mind
like you know you know it's interesting
for them to get into these fields and
then do what they do or one of the final
things i didn't want to ask you just
kind of like one thing i respect about
you is like
content is informative but you don't
take yourself like super seriously you
have fun you go out there you joking
like what kind of birthed that mentality
for you and then like are we ever gonna
get like angry brad says we ever gonna
get you pop it off on social media like
are we we gonna get messy blasters for
the clout
like a cloud
is honestly just my childhood i grew up
i'm the younger i have two older
brothers so i was always on the beating
end of everything yeah it doesn't like
here's a true story from my childhood i
didn't eat ketchup for like 10 years of
my life because my brothers convinced me
it was dog's blood oh i'm gay evil all
day
they don't want you taking all the
packages so there's like yo make sure
brad don't get no packages this dog
i don't know like being in that growing
up and like i had a great childhood
there's no complaints about my childhood
but it's like that's the that's what i
like ketchup for a little brother
so
if you're gonna win fights in my
household at that age because my dad
would always tell me he's like don't
start something you can't finish
and like i learned a couple times like
you know i was on the losing end but i
could win with just wit yeah that was
the only way and just be smarter and if
i know that if i approached mom and like
i could convince her that i was the
happy child and they were the angry one
i could get away with stuff guys
psychological warfare
you know it's funny he's yeah he's he's
like all right you know i'm gonna have a
hard time beating my brothers fair and
square so i'm gonna turn the parents
against him that's why i love it though
he would put little things out of place
to say i don't know who did that thing
[Laughter]
[Music]
that it's awesome we love to see the
girls through the channel and you
continue on your journey the vp or
starduck is just absolutely startup is
absolutely amazing to me and you just
continue to keep rising it's always
informative definitely blessed to have
you so we definitely gotta ask you a
question that we asked
all the lords here in the realm the
guests i need lord brad sanders top five
video games or franchises of all time oh
see like that's yeah pressure pick from
your kids you knew it was coming brad
let's be real here i mean like
it's easy it's i should say it's easier
for me to pick five that are awesome
than to like stack rank them because
right on one on one hand like for me
it's real easy it's like call of duty
okay but but but at the same time the
reason why call of duty is up there is
the games or whatever like right it's
the camaraderie i have you know getting
four guys into a helicopter and we just
go screwing around and like when we
smash into a wall and blow up and all
die like that's the best part like it's
not the game yes it's the experience the
friendship of it absolutely that's why
i've definitely put call of duty up
there halo's in there instantly as well
you know despite the tossing and turning
of halo it was my childhood uh just
playing capture the flag getting in
warthog
that was that was my
college and and high school timeline
like perfect in there
um i still i really like forza even
though i suck at it
motorsport over motorsport over horizon
uh i would take them both like i mean
like
like a new hot wheels expansion that
just came out uh on horizon is fantastic
but i like cars and i know i'll never be
able to afford a power
so it's like that's that's that's in
there all right we got four of these
three um another classic
is
and it's not even their newer ones but
tiger woods 2012 tiger woods golf
that was the last one when he was on the
cover right yeah yeah because they did i
think his 2016 was rory yeah again but
it's like i like golf but 2012 was it
was again like get the buddies together
that was one of the best ones too
exactly
it was they those down in history for me
as the best golf game probably ever i
know they're rebooting it and there's a
new one coming out here soon which we'll
wait and see
uh and then there's like so many others
that fall into like just like madden for
example but like hey ncaa better than
madden like okay yeah yeah football from
back in the day back in the day yes
remember those titles oh
first person
football yes that was insane yes so
you know but then like there's a whole
handful of bethesda titles that you get
like i played diablo
man you gotta pick them down you only
got five
no it's tough tiger and uh
last one be command and conquer like the
credit conquer series nice i like that
i think that's our first commando
command of concert yeah that this is
different to a lot of the stuff that we
get yeah but you can tell but but his
path is different he's meeting men in
bars that actually gives him jobs
like it's so random i need to go to the
boss
[Laughter]
you're ridiculous so kind of you to
offer i don't ridiculous every final
question we asked
[Laughter]
i think i know what ecosystem is going
to be here but i got to ask anyway
favorite console of all time and why
playstation 4.
that'll throw everybody for a loop
hey whatever you saying that'll be dope
as hell
okay so favorite console of all time
uh somebody might call me and say brad
but you said you bought every single one
i eventually did oh but my favorite
console and this is way more sappy than
it should be is the xbox 360.
reason being talk to us
i did not get one at launch and i wasn't
she wasn't my wife yet
but my soon-to-be wife and her my
soon-to-be father-in-law went and stayed
at a best buy for hours because they had
a specific allotment and she got me it
for christmas
like i was completely blown away and i
opened it up like you did that and then
we eventually got married oh no you had
to marry you had to be that's a keeper
right there yeah i've seen best friends
that don't even sit on the line for
nobody knowing the line
right there
braven braving the line it's danger
involved
and then she got her pops to go where
absolutely that's a that's a wonderful
woman absolutely i actually love your
choice salute salute tremendous
tremendous games history tremendous
journey i love hearing these type of
stories we still got a couple more
questions and stuff that we got topics
we got to get into but uh sorry if you
want to get i'll get the uh paul and
then you get this actually i'll do the
poll after um you wanna just jump right
in or we'll do super super chats after
uh
how many money super chats i'm gonna say
no that's not too many okay cool hold on
a second we have
target chinese once again two dollar
super chat so when does microsoft
acquire embracer
then we can be acquired by proxy that's
what he means that's what he means
then we have runaway dragons tv five
dollar super chat
i can have some on the show yeah i will
bribe him with some homemade coquito
what's good hi guys hello addict on more
shows for the win facts hello yeah i
only want to wait an appearance for like
two yeah you owe one away
do not buy that crappy god of war statue
buy the prime one oh lord here we go
statue [ __ ] get that one get the real
one
continue we've got face 23 b b k ny 20
super chat xbox fans death stranding is
garbage
now it's great but it's only on pc game
pass not on console xbox is treating the
console gamer as a second class citizen
and it's the original not the definitive
edition there's a lot of a lot of
emotions a lot of hurt and there's not a
lot of tears a lot of them
and what i would say is i don't care
what you say i know it hurts
here's some salt for your wounds
it takes some dog's blood to put on top
moving on
wow we got tony bryant member for 25
months happy to be here live enjoying
the bs on today's show also lords is it
better for you if we do lord gold level
on youtube or patreon as always great
time to be a gamer
wherever you go is it's great for us it
doesn't matter whatever you feel you get
the most out of yeah yeah yeah either
your choice your choice well that was
good
for you
nope emojis though over here yes yes get
the emojis over here
we have ryan ginther five dollar super
chat got the shenron glider buy your
xbox in 2023 since the games might show
up then and ragged rock is coming
also saab is the culture of iop okay
yeah that's right that he's outside zone
and your game you're gonna have to pour
some sauzon on it because it's coming in
oh my god you're gonna have to season it
to keep it to keep it ready for 2023.
put it in the freezer
there we go
hard to find member for 16 months
assalamu alaikum to my brothers so much
love fellas y'all are the reason i look
forward to sunday thank you brother much
appreciation welcome so long
okay one second let me roll back a
little bit i got drawn tj five dollar
super chat morning lords hope you guys
have a great day when does sony get out
of the console business oh my god oh my
god them to this generation
then we have drive by joe
oh
a little too much information in that
name but that's fine
five dollars statues of limitations
brother
and
and he says to brad marry her and her
pops yeah
that's when you know the father-in-law
likes you if he's gonna stand online for
you yes that's a good one then we have
mr blt's ten dollars to a chat
addict debating porter rock was like
frieza backing goku into a corner and
attic going super saiyan on him respect
to both porto not as toxic as his
twitter persona would make you believe
yeah
um we played on playstation when i did
turn it on and oh my god really cool
absolutely right
we're good we're caught up oh we got it
all right cool we got
hold on no no no i see oh
my mic fell off my desk again you have
to give me yeah i got your problem okay
we have east texas alex 10 super chat
hello everyone this is my first time in
a while catching you guys live god bless
you all thank you hit that like button
we have a 500 almost 600 people in here
fantastic
please i was wondering what king is
drinking but i'm sure it's the tears of
them sony family oh no what i did make
some tears in here but this is lemonade
mixed with uh strawberry lemonade
because one tastes better than that
mixed
get the best of both worlds okay yes we
got gerald mack member for 23 months
all hail the iop could not find the
comment section for the merch order all
black all natty on the way oh now i hope
you found it if not let us know yeah let
us know
that we have done otaku five dollar
super chat even on game pass death
stranding is still dog poop oh my god i
don't want to hear those people having
revelations about this trash was
actually good shaking my head
what if people wanted people to enjoy it
you can't just enjoy it
you paid that money to play it so you
found out it was trash with cash we're
gonna find out it's trash for free
the difference
they went in your wallet excuse me and
they took 70.
you found out it was trash we're going
to go inside and peek
and it hurts nobody i can't but you're
not the field dominance maximus really
expensive
good run tj yeah
great guest for your podcast hi brad
no no all right let's get into that
goodness
oh we got what's up we good no i think
we're good right there
let's get into this topic man so this is
me uh embracer
lots of acquisitions
going all we got to talk about it so it
looks like embracer group acquires the
lord of the rings i p tripwire limited
run and more so for further context they
acquired the middle earth enterprises
limited run sing tricks via their new
division free mode tripwire interactive
tuxedo labs acquired via
subsidiary saber interactive and they
had an additional acquisition which
remains unannounced which i thought was
interesting
aggregated upfront purchase price
reaches
576 million and according to the
purchase foreign agreement not only is
the middle earth enterprise
enterprises division they own the lord
of the rings and the hobbit
for over 50 years
they said that the uh also the
acquisition may include matching rights
and other middle-earth related literary
works authorized by the tokyo to state
and harper collins which have yet to be
explored and yeah this has been shaking
the internet as far as just the the
scope of this so let's start with you
lord brass says like what do you make of
this acquisition in general when the
news came across your line i want to
know how they kept all this quiet
i mean let's just be like they didn't
come out and say hey guys we're buying
one studio they're gonna like they just
said like here it is and it just like
plopped out onto the internet and
everyone's just like they did what yeah
and
nobody really scooped this in any
meaningful way you know like that being
said
we've seen this group snatch up just
tons of ip clearly they have a big end
game in mind and it's just to bring in
just as much ip as you can because i
think they look at it the same way
microsoft does like hey we see what
netflix is we see what disney is there's
gonna be a gaming company that
eventually wins that's just sort of
content on demand which is like what we
look at game pass and i bet that this
company or
holding group as you want to call them
sees it the same way like look we can be
a one-stop shop where an amazon a google
a sony could come and just write a
massive check and just take the whole ip
industry with them and that's like sort
of like the logical business reason
because at the same time
shipping video games is incredibly
difficult
it's not easy it's not easy to do this
stuff and get a 90 metacritic score and
all that stuff and i have all these
studios under there it's like
it just seems i don't know we'll we'll
see how this shakes out i think it's
it's fascinating from a business
perspective yeah i wanted to follow up a
question with you because you made some
fantastic points here and i guess like
you said like trying to figure out the
end game on one hand you make a great
points about the ip the other thing i
think is interesting is you know i know
a lot of gamers when you know they look
at the microsoft acquisition and they
say man you know activision blizzard
king and all this stuff and microsoft
kind of it still has one foot in the
console business but what i find
interesting there is no embracer console
right so do you think like what do you
think with this ip gathering like what
do you think just a distribution model
just be pure cloud like or just just
control ips like what do you think about
that
i would be shocked to see them build
something hardware really the only
reason i say that is hardware is
notoriously low margin like we all know
that microsoft and sony when these
consoles come out like hey they're
losing money on this stuff hoping that
they're gonna make a few bucks every
time you buy a game and they'll win it
back through that sort of a strategy i
think that they just end up in a
like i mean video games can be
incredibly proud i mean look at eldon
ring is i guess a bad example because
they like really ratcheted up the bar
like what insanity can be but video
games can be quite profitable from a
software perspective if you can get
quality titles out on a schedule like
what microsoft is trying to do with game
pass and so
i don't have a i don't think they would
be build a console i think they continue
with the strategy of like hey let's put
it on all the consoles out there let's
put it in uh you know on steam as we see
sony doing because very clearly it's
profitable and advantageous to do that
uh that's where i think that they they
stay now i mean at the same time if you
would have said hey brad do you think
embracer's going to buy nine studios in
the single announcement
nuts
yeah it's crazy just covered off of what
is it uh the some of the crystal
dynamics stuff and you know they're back
at it again and last what i was going to
ask you is just like what do you feel
about
the
besides the games like get into the
movie industry like this is
tolkien this is lord of the rings
outside like what do you think the end
game is there just consolidate all these
different forms of entertainment
well i mean you got to look at it like
from like stepping back a little bit
building an ip is incredibly expensive
like to build a a hobbit stability harry
potter brand is incredibly expensive so
the fact that they already have one on
the movie side i think we're going to
see more of that sort of a crossover
between movie and video game because i
think it's a natural extension of what
can be done with ip these days because
so for so long it's like okay i mean we
all know what happened with star wars
right you have the movie yeah and you
have little action figures and you don't
know how he made tons of money on the
idea right on the action figures but
that's extending and it has been for a
while to video games uh spider-man
perfect example yes and so i think we're
gonna start to see potentially even more
storytelling just move into the gaming
industry it's like hey i watched the
movie now let's continue the novel or
the canon line and this video game is
gonna be potentially an avenue that
happens no i hear you great point so
lord addict embrace a group did it
surprise you was it was you startled
at this point anyone buying anything
doesn't surprise me
it's just
i think we're in that point where
people are openly selling because
i think value on just about anything's
high right now
and you know it's it's it's like brad
said you know it's easier just to
to steal someone else well that's still
to buy someone else's work than it is to
make your own uh financially time-wise
because keep in mind it's more than into
finances too it takes time doing that
and yeah you know we see stuff like
you know how long it took to build
something like the marvel mcu mm-hmm you
know this took
10-15 years and you know you see
something like dc where you know they
don't necessarily look like they want to
give it that time
that's an example of people that got the
money but they don't want to put the
time in either
so it's easier to go through them like
yo you know you guys ain't really doing
much with that lord of the rings you
know
i feel like i feel like we can find a
good place for it
the biggest thing i want is just you
know i want better games i want good
lord of the rings games you know shadow
of war shadow mordor i want that that
that lore to be expanded on
as long as that is what this leads to
i'm 100 okay with it and if it doesn't
it's like what are we going to do it's
like i just want
this consolidation
only works to me
if it betters games in the long run i
feel that uh to me if you get a lot of
this consolidation like microsoft buying
all these studios sony buying all these
studios even nintendo to a point and
nothing's done with the ips that these
studios own
then at that point it's like okay now
we're backtracking but it's just like
you know
i just want to see evolution in the
industry i want to see new ideas be
expanded on because it's probably the
reason a lot of these studios haven't
really tried anything like drastically
news because they were put in a box and
said make call of duty
and i'm hoping you know with with those
chains a little bit lifted i don't think
people act like every day every studio
is making call of duty is just going to
be allowed to do anything they want i
don't think that i feel like there's
going to be a few of those studios still
working on call of duty because that's
that's too much of a cash grave gravy
chain but you know maybe they'll free up
one or two studios i was working on call
of duty to do something else and that
that's what i want you know with the
embrasure group thing i want to see more
lord of the rings games quality lord of
the rings games and the only the only
worry i have is
they'll take the ips and they won't
they won't properly fund them
because they will want to just write off
the name instead of not necessarily the
game they're not making it
okay yeah so what we'll just have to see
you know at the end of the day uh time
is
the only thing we really got so
uh we got to see exactly what comes out
of this you know
for all we know because then bryce's
girl bought that we get some of the best
lord of the rings games in the next 10
years on demand yeah a good point good
point there's an interesting parallel
something to watch
let's go
harry potter right there's a big harry
potter game coming out and regardless if
you're a harry potter fan or whatnot you
can see how they can take what they're
doing with harry potter and bring it
over to these ips yes and i guarantee
that everyone's watching to see you know
from a media perspective like who owns
these ips from like let's let's like if
harry potter spent you know 100 million
bucks to build this title and they knock
it out of the park
maybe we get some interesting stuff it's
funny you say that brad because i've
been on team hashtag just one and
popular ips and pop culture for
microsoft to do and i get a ridicule all
the time they should pretty much says do
everything yeah they people tell me all
the time they i i don't want microsoft
bearing others i want them to make their
type of games but if we see success
right and these pop culture titles and
you see a game like spider-man run
around like it'd be nice to kind of have
one of those in your toolbox if you ask
me that's just
but anyways let me stop the advice
off embrace the group what you feeling
the precious has been embraced
listen you know unlike a lot of the the
conversations around it that you know
the consolidation is bad for the
industry i'm scared
no wow well i'm gonna tell you right now
i love what embracer is doing we shout
out to the guys over on the uh
the doomsayers podcast we were talking
about this on friday um and you know
pong soul was on as well and we talked a
lot about yeah pong is spawning is
amazing and there's split
dropping and plugging here we go
but this is the thing you know this is
what happens when you actually go on
other shows
but um yeah i'm happy about this because
a lot of the ip that they're acquiring a
stuff that i love right that was this
this this double a tier type of game
that we just kind of lost for a long
time that that sort of that level of
game disappeared a lot of these ip have
been
dormant for a very long time and all of
a sudden
embracer picks them up
and you know with the willingness to
bring them forward and make them
playable you know for for the modern
audiences remaking them remastering them
while at the same time making a
commitment to bring them back
better than they were before right
because the game plan is to bring these
these ip back give you the remasters
give you the remakes and then make new
games in in these franchises and make
them and gradually turn them into more
aaa type products this is something that
would have never happened under square
enix under any other sort of holding
company or developer that had control of
these ips it wasn't going to happen
embrace this whole point is that right
and and to speaking to
you know kind of the the scatter shot
nature of what you know what it seems
that they're acquiring
they're looking at what disney is
they're looking at what warner is they
want to be this multimedia conglomerate
where all of these ips live and to
brad's point when he says it's super the
hardest thing to do is to bring an ip to
build one up brand new
and to sell it and to make it into a
franchise you have a lot of these games
already franchises and bringing the game
to fruition and bringing the game to
market is just difficult so if you have
these ip that you think have this reach
across multimedia then okay if if the
game if the game doesn't sell as well as
he wanted to but hey it's maybe it's
super popular and then you're gonna get
this this this cartoon from it or a
movie from it you know look at you could
cyberpunk right cyberpunk a lot of the a
lot of the love that was
around cyberpunk before his launch kind
of dissipated after the whole launch
fiasco right but then you have like this
netflix show that people seem excited
about and you have other things around
cyberpunk and you have you know the
witcher could have just suffered from
that just because by proxy even though
the witcher products people are pretty
much happy with but the witcher show
could have suffered just because it was
a cdpr thing and it didn't so
i think what they're doing is
diversifying in a way that makes sense
getting these and you know and luckily
for me it's ip that have been dormant
for a long time they have legacy of kane
now they have thieves they have dave's
ex like imagine them bringing those back
in a real way
um
no other i don't i don't see anybody
else with the willingness to put the
money into these ips to have that happen
so i'm happy i'm happy i understand
people's concern about the gobbling up
all this stuff
but the alternative is it dies
and i am not in that boat where it's
like oh survival of the fittest whatever
if it has to die it has to die because
the reality is that you see dice because
the reality is that's not the nature of
the game industry anymore if you have
these if this consolidation is happening
because it is happening
i'm happy with these companies surviving
in some way shape or form being
purchased by a bigger entity and
surviving as opposed to them dying and
these franchises dying that's right
lord king embrace a group
we have six hundred and almost six
hundred and fifty yeah yeah like y'all
we have brad sams in here and that's the
fastest we ever got through intros yeah
we're breaking it right not even the two
o'clock yeah we are breaking a record
for brands
ultimate
by not you know digging into one of my
favorite journalists slash youtube dudes
and
digging into his past because these
dudes got a chain on me so if i'm
restraint today
this is the reason why we're trying to
get the most out of bravo man listen
brad has to come back so i can actually
get real questions from absolutely okay
okay
all right but um embrace a group
this their business model is acquiring a
whole bunch of assets because right now
cash isn't really good right so if
you're looking at cash and if it's
sitting in the bank addict brought this
up yesterday and and i had to think
about it the the
the way that we're moving in this
recession uh cash is being devalued over
time very quickly in a rapid pace right
so what you do is you go out and you
require a bunch of assets you go spend
all the money that you can because that
money is today's money
will be less tomorrow right so you
you acquire them now
the assets will only grow in value right
so when the assets grow in value you do
a couple of things with these assets you
can sell them you can market them you
can go back then you can take games that
are already made remaster these games
peak interest see
where the interest lies in these games
now they will never make a console
because if they did make a console we
would have been new about these
acquisitions right
we would have known that they were in
the mix because what happens
um console makers
they snitch
all right and they're out there they're
pointing yo yo yo this dude's buying up
too much stuff oh my god
and this is i can't survive if they if
they're buying the stuff and they're
pointing and you would like this i'm
just saying i'm not saying no names
today
oh good okay i can bring brad down the
rabbit hole with me
who's brad
[Laughter]
you know so they know they see the
snitch and they're like we don't want
none of that culture what we want to do
is we want to facilitate
so they're going to be the facilitators
for for a period of time they're going
to build these ips up and then if
somebody's really interested in them
they can sell them like oh oh or they're
the bag man like if somebody's in
trouble like don't worry about it i'll
pick up these ips when you get out of
trouble or slide them back over remember
i told you i embraced the group
microsoft tight as hell um
so i honestly believe that you know we
won't know the end game of embracer
group because what they realize is cash
is devalued assets mean more money and
assets can bring in more money wasn't
this brought up from embracing group was
like the remnants of thq well yeah it
was like kind of the reference of tsq
thq nordic
you know kind of it's all under one
umbrella right remember that so we
watched thq and thq nordic go under
mm-hmm or not nordic hq
yeah yeah so what what did we see they
turned into a bigger monster than
themselves he sat back and it was like
all right how did we do this what went
wrong and they reinvented themselves and
they reinvented their self into this
juggernaut that everybody's just
worrying about who's microsoft and sony
acquiring right y'all are not watching
these dudes
10 cents these dudes intense and fingers
are everywhere yeah but they're grabbing
ips so what's off said and i and i and i
like the fact that they do get the
eyepiece and don't sit on them
they tell you okay yeah we got these
from here and what we're trying to do
and what we want to do so they give you
hope where there was no hope you get
hope now so
if they continue to do how they how
they're working
i appreciate it um
the fact that they got the lord of the
rings and stuff like that makes no never
mind i mean
i don't care where these games come from
to be honest with you if they're on the
platform of choice that i play i'm i'm
gonna play uh so they can acquire as
much as they want i don't think
acquisitions are bad because if you're
looking at the people or the the people
that's developing the games or the
people that made the games to see the
game that you made being remastered or
being remade and it was sitting on the
shelf yeah that makes you happy so
somewhere someplace they're making a ton
of people happy by these acquisitions
and it's not nothing to be feared you
know this is just bringing more content
to our space yeah i really really got
too much to add i mean everyone knocked
it out the park with most of my thoughts
especially with where brad was coming
from um you know look it's a huge it's a
huge deal i mean they dave
prior to this obviously the acquisitions
was idols and you know tomb raider stuff
and you know they've they've been
quietly just
acquiring acquiring and this is
definitely a substantial move i think
for me the surprise is
when i asked brad is like how is no one
competing for the lord of rings
right
like i just found that interesting that
you know maybe the maybe the bag was
just that big and insurmountable to
compete but i just found it interesting
because i look at like amazon i'm like
would that have made sense amazon if you
would have kind of jumped in there in
the mix you know with lord of the rings
and i i just think that is a huge deal
and it coupled with um
you know i'm a huge limited run fan
because like they they preserve physical
they go out their way they keep trying
to give the old classic feel you know
for all the older heads like me you know
what i say i really i really respect
that um i just again you know i guess
the question what what's like what's the
end game what's the what's the end game
for embracer and maybe you can't get
good at it i was just gonna say like i
think the thing that we're not looking
at this too is this might just look like
buying ips but
these ips can grow
you know this lord of the lord of the
rings tv show about to pop up on amazon
you know once that pops off and it's
like the next game of thrones
and then that throws off spin awesome
before you know it they made the lord of
the rings license more expensive so no
absolutely absolutely that's that's the
benefit like brad would say you look at
the you know the uh what you call it the
uh that the
harry potter i always forget to cook you
you know you know the one with the kids
with the wow
that one highly disrespectful yeah
clearly clearly you can tell i'm not a
connoisseur clearly clearly he's not
clearly i've done it and he's from
england yeah
[Laughter]
anyway it's just so you know you can see
the power of having that ip and then
like brad was saying you got that the
merging of the movies the gaming you
know you could really benefit if you
have this really successful you know pop
culture kind of idea the other thing is
going under the radar is like they
acquired a japanese studio in this yes
yeah what is it tatsujin is in there
it's just insane you know what's going
on my only i saw i'm with you with
overall acquisition you know i blowed
acquisition too so i'm with you there my
only concern is just i want to see how
they from a management standpoint yeah
it's a lot to manage it it's a lot to
manage but i think when you look at what
they're doing
they have direction right where you look
at tencent what tencent's doing
everybody's like what the hell are they
doing well they're just acquiring things
to own things and to have a bigger stake
in the gaming industry period right and
they don't seem like they they're too
interested at these at least at this
point to interfere too much in the
business of games just here take this
money do what you always do
whereas embracer is in a quarter we
expect our chat exactly exactly but
embracer
is also kind of not interfering but
they're they are enabling
uh a situation where like i said that
these ips and these these studios that
may not have an opportunity to make them
are going to have an opportunity to
bring them back and then you know like
you said limited run all this other
stuff it all falls into hey we want
these ips to have as far of a reach as
possible in a number of different media
right and i mean
it makes a whole lot of sense no
absolutely absolutely like i said we
just got to monitor that
you know it's it's so interesting to see
this games industry how it's moving and
yeah guys so i have a question for you
guys um
is uh because this was brought up on
friday and i think brad alluded to it a
little bit as well
what about the possibility of them
acquiring so much stuff that we get a
subscription service of just embrace
your stuff whether it be just games
movies tv so whatever it is that they do
with their iphone
i think it all goes back to trying to
understand what the end game is like we
can hypothesize about like what is the
nba that is a v like to me that's a very
logical point that they could move
towards the thing that they're going to
suffer on and i think a lot of us
agree with this is subscription fatigue
i mean
everything you've got now you've got
paramount you've got hbo which you want
yo is struggling and they're hbo yeah
and you've got all these things and then
here comes embracer it's like bam like
here's another one i'm not saying they
can't do it but even ea has struggled
with it and okay we all know how big
they are so it's not saying that again i
don't want to say they're not going to
because they'll be my luck they'll
announce it tomorrow
fatigue is like disney plus hit it
perfect they were right on the front of
that pandemic wave that was the right
time to launch a subscription gaming
service to i mean look at state like we
got one of these things right here
stadia how's that going yeah good point
no absolutely good tech good tech that's
great yeah good tech very good tech
absolutely tech is incredible it's just
they they cannot
launch a subscription service
without ruffling the feathers of the
other two
and
that would
see what what that what that effect
would be on the sony side and on the
microsoft side
that will force them to do what embrace
a group in
uh you know well 10 to a lesser extent
is doing
i doubt it i think they can actually
uh put a service together because they
will have to have actual servers to do
that this is where microsoft is in a
unique position where they don't suffer
with like a lot of other people yeah
they have that infrastructure backbone
right
i think they can put something and make
a little pack with uh both
uh um manufacturers
and servicing groups um and putting
their games into their um i think it's
more advantageous to put their games
into a little package into each service
opposed to actually taking them on
directly this way you're non-threatening
when you're when you're putting your
stuff on it and you're including so this
is how you skirt around the whole ftc
stuff and all that other
i think it does serve their best
interest to be everywhere right in some
way shape or form as opposed to being
just one place yeah i think a good thing
that you know some people are
overlooking is
with the consolidation that the console
manufacturers are doing where they're
buying these publishers like bethesda
activision
there does need to be other people
to come out of the the ashes
of those companies and replace them
yeah so you know i don't know if this i
don't know embrace your group or you
know any of the other companies are but
you do need some of these
you know double a publishers
to
to go into that aaa market maybe not
with all their games but enough to take
you know the bethesda's places and you
know kind of bring balance to the force
all right not fair enough look we've got
this topic the only last thing i'll say
attic i do agree with you also just as
long as the quality of these ips
maintain developers are allowed to do
what they need to do let's create the
products that we like i'm good i do what
i know we're at time with brad said i
know what brad has to do so but i did
want to add before he leaves i would
love to get his opinion on the next
topic before he goes oh god don't be
here for this you know
no i i just need him i need him
your stuff off but don't be here for
this
he can choose to do what he needs to do
but um yeah i saw i'm gonna hijack you a
little bit oh
death stranding uh to game pass pc um we
heard the news obviously uh announced on
xbox wire and um kajima production 505
games and i'm excited to announce that
and windows 10 11 pc gamers get the
features ultra wide mode photo mode high
frame rate crossover content it seems uh
xbox twitter had a little
fun with this as far as promotion and
getting behind it and stuff like that so
they knew what they were doing
you know lord brad man i got to ask you
what are your thoughts about death
stranded into pc game pass and are you
surprised by this not surprised candidly
i mean aside from the leaks like
you know even if the leaks didn't exist
i would still hold true to the statement
that one
video games are getting way more
expensive to build way more expensive
like to build a
triple a quad whatever you want to call
them high class shooter or any other
type of video game the cost associated
with that is growing faster than console
generational growth i mean phil spencer
even talked about it on stage he said
hey one of the problems we have with
consoles is that the average age of a
console gamer grows by one each year
it's because it's the same group of
people just moving along and so games
are getting just increasingly expensive
and i think i think this is more of the
start or where maybe we're in the middle
game because we've already seen sony's
like hey games are going on to steam
they're going onto pc because we realize
we can make money
not hurting sales
and so death training coming to xbox is
more of an emotional win in my opinion
than anything else it's a look this is
the future of the industry companies
need to make money sony's looking at a
back catalog of like look we got all
this stuff back here it's making next to
nothing every month
if we throw it into game pass yeah it
looks kind of awkward but at the same
time
you know we're we're in this to make
money right we're a game studio and a
hardware maker and if this sells us more
makes us more money so we can invest
more into the next titles or the next
consoles like that's the industry in a
nutshell that's right brad so so brad i
got to ask you then so there's a thing
that's confidence and they put in a
successful
effort
so there's a conversation about on on on
the internet oh god oh god about whether
sony had any control over this
what is your i don't think what are your
thoughts on this
i don't know like those are contract
line items and those are always
difficult to weed out because hey it in
fairness it's not like this game came
out last week this game has been playing
through the industry for a while this
has been there and so maybe it really
was like hey we got x amount of years
and after until yep you can do whatever
you want except put it on the xbox
console and
what would be hilarious is if like xbox
game pass or pc wasn't even like a
consideration when the initial contract
was signed then all of a sudden it's
like hey
yeah that's the loophole that means
microsoft legal team is ill if they knew
when the gate was up
i can't wait to talk but continue game
yeah oh i think we'll see i don't know
necessarily more about this going into
game pass but i think we will see more
of like i kind of talked about it in the
podcast i did on my by myself like
the definition aside from nintendo
nintendo is always the outlier the
exclusive
is effectively kind of dead right what
we think of like oh i got to buy
nintendo 64. if i want to play goldeneye
that era is now gone now right still
remains you know sort of in the flesh
and bones of like hey spider-man's only
available on console and pc it's not
available on xbox but soon hardcore
definition isn't is known but there's a
certain subset of people on twitter that
feel you know very emotional about this
very very tied to to this being with one
platform and are upset but another
picture on friday just my stupid
computer has led lights like everybody
else does and i turned them blue and i
said i love my new playstation and man
oh yeah
you had the pieces so angry it's like
like and then i did a green one like
here's my xbox like people people say
this like i attacked their mother
the emotionality brad are you implied
there's a lot of emotionality within the
games
fans
there's way too much emotion involved in
the wrong way like go join habitat
humanity with that same energy and you
will solve so much
i feel you brother luck man i know it's
so easy i know you had time i had you
gotta get the most out of you first of
all the legendary brad sam finally in
the realm of iop we definitely get
everybody gotta bring you back thank you
so much for spending the time
so tell the people before you leave
where to find people can find you what
you got going on you know the easiest
way is just on the hell site known as
twitter it's just bd sams um same on
youtube is just bd sams i try to get
that i that name wherever i can so it's
just twitter and youtube that's probably
the best way to to harass me no doubt
brother you're a legend we love the
information
absolute pleasure brad sands in the
building brother thank you
salute so um yeah so so sorry you read
attic i believe you are up
so uh yeah man as far as the death
stranding thing
[Music]
playstation pc launches
let's go let's go ahead and go go go
i mean
it's it's it's a funny thing it's like
look like i'm still one of the like i
don't care what people say people sit
there and you know they act like
sony doesn't have no involved with this
whatsoever like they they literally act
like sony has been finessed by multiple
lawyer firms
and it's like oh no this had nothing to
do with that 505 made this and i'm like
still victims
yeah so i'm just like so we are really
trying to sit here and say that 505 got
one in on tony yeah i know right like
that makes no sense to me i
i agree with you there but i do think
this is more about microsoft
finessing
looking at your contract
as a po i agree with you i don't think
it's
dumb foul fight just you know i'm saying
getting getting getting over but i do
think myself would be be really combing
through to see when they could they
could jump in the mix
i think this is one of one of those
scenarios where it's like
death stranding they didn't say any
sales wise whatsoever i don't think that
game sold well i think it probably hit
profit but i don't think it made them as
much money as they thought especially
how much money they put in anybody
you don't they marketed it like crazy so
i think their mindsets like look like
this isn't like this isn't one of our
games really this is a second party
thing we don't own the studio and then
you know microsoft's probably been
throwing out cash money everywhere when
it comes to game pass is and it's
already on pc
it's like look like let's just literally
take the work we've already did to put
it on pc and just let them have it in
game pass to take that check like i
don't think like it's not a god of war
it's not the last of us right but the
fact that we ain't gonna do that that
was this is this was on a box this is
like this is
we this is the god but the fact that
people yeah
the fact that people are sitting there
saying and i think what death strategy
came out on pc like what a year and a
half ago or something like that
yeah it wasn't even that long ago so
like people are literally trying to
convince me that 505's lawyers is oh you
know what we're doing do we we go put in
little little letters little letters
down here no it's like look like it
comes with like the mlb thing like look
i think that was a little bit more on
mob's side but sony could have easily
have leveraged it away from it but it's
just like they just making the game not
what mlb that was good
it was a strong arm tactic by the mlb
over sony it's like we feel our game
would be better served on multiple
platforms even though you and you have
it currently exclusive if you continue
to make it exclusive we will take the
license from you and go elsewhere and
you're right sony then
sony's sitting at the table eating lunch
by himself what the hell you mean nobody
else can come over here and sit down yo
i just think it was one of those stop
your crap
we gonna take it from you and he said
everybody can sit down i personally feel
like that conversation probably went
with
kind of like what you saw with the fifa
all right we feel like
this ip deserves more money yes or you
make it multi-player yeah and sony's
like i'm not paying you more money i'll
make a multi-player like yeah could be
that's how i could be no i know that
that that it very well could be yes
it's just like to to me
it's just you know i i don't think i
think
i personally don't feel like sony is
completely anti-everything like people
claim like it's just like you know and
what's funny is like people want to
throw that perspective on uh you know
they didn't put stuff on pc this they
didn't do that it's like dude they have
done a lot drastically changing their
company in the past like two to three
years
like it it it this isn't like small
changes like
anything is possible for them doing
because they have changed so much this
is not the same people running the
company that was running it factual five
six years ago this is a a set of new
people and i personally feel like and i
know people don't agree because uh
people were on me on jazz's podcast
throwing kisses at the chat and somebody
in the chat might think it's for them i
just want to make sure it's clear
i apologize i interrupted sorry i i just
personally feel like you know sony's
like look
you know death strainings that ip we're
gonna invest into
but we're gonna milk every last drop out
of this orange that we can
and uh you know they they went to i
wouldn't be surprised if this showed up
on stadium next week right
it's just at this point they're like
well you get what i'm saying yeah i know
we just we just need to make more money
and i think that's their mindset
especially since it's not their stuff
like they might own the ip they own the
trademark but i don't think that if you
like talk to the actual higher-ups of
playstation i don't think none of them
really consider death stranding theirs
because i think
but they only never know
but the thing is it's it's it's it's
like
microsoft i'm sure if you went up to
there and say yo
do you consider recoil your game they're
going to say we own it but we can't make
it and i think that you know for for a
company to feel like it's truly theirs
they have to be able to do it all and
they would have to go out find a new
studio to make record find a new studio
to make these games like that's why phil
was very
like open it's like i'm done doing
second party deals i want to own the
studio because what's the point of
owning an ip that is useless without a
studio to make it
enough
lord king sending me funny messages
during this oh you said that that's dope
right you're hilarious we're not showing
that oh i don't even know i definitely
don't want that
oh no
you see what you did
you see what you did apologies
we gonna break protocol right now
shout out to two dollar super chat let
me play with your joystick oh my god is
soft blowing kisses at me heart emoji
face kiss emoji face i love you too song
yes i told you be careful he on deck
literally
he or she he or she
[Music]
here we go who do we love
i don't like you with these numbers
five
oh
oh say it with me now
hey all you saudi dudes you remember i
was like oh that's randy's crap oh this
is that a third it's better over here
oh that was fire now
yeah it's fire there because it's yeah
this is what it do baby oh my god now
you care about it now i love it i love
it
listen man
i saw somebody say what they say oh it's
crap right you found out cause you paid
70 dollars plus tax
the dream of the god came off the
mountain and blessed you
he was like
you ain't got this king you ain't got
this and what i said i don't care about
your walking simulator you did say that
i don't i don't care about delivering
packages i can't now
oh now you can test it
now
you know why i can't right now i'm
kidding this is free for me
it's free for me but guess what i'm
gonna find out i'm gonna find out if the
words that you're saying out your mouth
is wack see sometimes
it's wet because you had to pay for it
you know what's the best thing in life
it's free
things in life is free
yeah you can't experience that because
they got you okay
why are you trying to act like this
here we come after benefit is
playstations for the players
yeah you got and y'all don't buy no
games if y'all would have brought the
game this would have never happened
so you implied that this is their fault
yo the god came off the mountain bless
y'all with the gang said no metal dead
you know what i'm saying yes right
kajima that's right and none of y'all
went out of support
y'all y'all like the family members that
didn't push this demo you didn't push
this down
that's what happened he got to go get
the bag where the bag is got it shout
out to 505 for understanding how to get
that finesse that wallet you refine
i love the finesse i don't like that you
have a 505 or a deck
you have all of those this is
prophesized it was prophesied
505. yo you guys don't really understand
what's happening here
y'all at the home of the bangers
y'all not the home of ex you are no
longer y'all walk around every day
looking at your eyepiece like who's
going to turn on me now
who's the traitor
we're actively playing a game of among
us
yo
yo that was the bars
who the hell is going to betray us
who's the killer
you got a wall
did you spiderman
are you implied no no ip is safe from
exclusivity they're walking around with
hayachi face all of them
and the best part about it the puppet
master the background is jim's dance
moves ryan
he got your belief in everything y'all
was like yeah we believe in generations
why are you the puppet master you guys
fell for it he'll climb this thinker
you know this is the greatest thing that
happened and i don't know what to say is
whack
we ain't paying for it
i love your enthusiasm for it all of a
sudden
i love i love the fact that they
financed our fun you guys went out
purchase it partake tried it and we came
through and said you know what
you're right
but it was delicious because it was free
and it's for me
i i i waited i waited for this day
i waited for this day i waited for this
day
i waited like
i can't even spider-man slid over the pc
wait just when spider-man go to pc uh
gary pass
the connections
so are you right now are you are you
implying that because there's another
the discussion that all that or the
advertising there's a there's a logo of
a spider on the um or the death
stranding box or whatever are you
implying that boar's coming at a certain
spider-man
i'm implying that playstation tears
tastes delicious
and and and you guys see it's red right
strategic
strategic
jeff shandon was already on pc
they just slid that over the game pass
pc let's get some more bucks over here i
demand already on pc
i can't i can't buy the wall ready on pc
[Music]
horizon and i'm ready on pc so while
you're playing the active game of among
us to kill it is jim
the killer is
killing people acting like a jessica's
gym over there working on the side and
y'all like i see him kill nobody
and he playing killing them softly with
his son
he got laura hill in his back pocket you
got a diet slow and yo oh kelly i love
you too baby
it's a premium boss my king he clearly
had a lot to say here um
yeah this is i guess i'll go oh this is
very intriguing to me
but listen i i will be right i'm gonna
give king since flowers today i'll i'll
indulge in a little of messiness today
listen we have to shout out
the greatest shelf
in the history of gaming
put your hands together phil dobbins max
in the show
put your hands together fulfill that
cause that man
had that looted statue and everybody was
like why does he have a death strand and
looted
statue in his background would he be
podcasting and listen
nintendo switch you next i don't so he
thumbs up there he it's everything has
been prophesized with this shelf this
shelf is no there's no game he know what
he do you know this can't he be setting
the subliminals he's a chess player yeah
he's a chess player like but he's a dude
that you know he want he he's the
nefarious super villain yeah yeah yeah
he said yeah someone said the the shelf
don't lie yeah
i will indulge in that messiness that
that shelf has proven to be completely
by um so i do appreciate the commissary
you know thank you
man you should have bought some raw you
should have bought some ramen noodles
those are cigarettes
that's how you sound to me r kelly
[Laughter]
[Music]
what did they fund what did they fund
fund me bank
it's interesting like you said you know
sodium's ip but you know 505 is
controlling this poor and
look microsoft's lawyers man they're
strategic they knew what they were doing
i agree with brad i think this was more
about the optics in the marketing
more
it held value for them because they
couldn't wait solve to be promoting this
they're jumping on xbox wires the whole
post like this was you could tell the
marketing team was gleaming they
couldn't wait to tell people this was
happening so to me i look at it like you
knew when the date was up as far as the
exclusivity you know what i'm saying or
on on maybe a competing service maybe at
that point the language with pc game
pass maybe not even existing and then at
that point when jeff stranded came out
let's be honest sony wasn't really
invested in pc at that point that was
the older era where they're kind of like
yo carlson exclusive and maybe there was
that workaround and legally they just
put that in they waited for that time to
run out and you know is it to the extent
of the mlb deal no but this does hold
weight and i'm gonna be honest look i'm
not adding you know me and you like i'm
not gonna cap for this game when the
game came out i was like it don't look
like for me
i'm gonna be 100 on it you know i'm
saying like it looked like the fedex
joint graphically it looked nice but i
wasn't paying 60 70 or whatever it was
but i have to agree with king
if you want to tell me free 99 to go
take go take a peek
hell yeah i would take a pig
like that's all you guys man
and i feel that but that to me that's
not capping like cabin is if i'm like
now that it's in here and i'm like yeah
that's my favorite game and i'm going in
and then that no because i didn't buy it
you know what i'm saying but that's the
beauty of game pass because
you're gonna get to find out about this
wonderful story oh no absolutely i'm
going to find out what's the deal on a
little on a smaller base but the thing i
think that's the beauty of game pass in
the sense that in this industry yes
there's going to be people that's going
to pay the 60 to 70 and salute that's
what you you do pay 60 70 for what no
not
that's 70 plus baby that's a 70 plus
that was david's market
baby
shout out to the 700 plus in here like
share subscribe pass that on to a friend
actually they got tears right now so
hand it to a sony dude
yeah i really think i really think
though
somebody had no idea like no they can't
do it no they knew i just think they
could do anything about it though
especially the game past thing
listen if you were my lawyer and you
didn't catch this name and language a
long time ago you're fired i can finally
feel you so like the moment
your job is to watch what the other team
is doing to make sure there are no
loopholes right i feel like i just i
feel that i mean
you could be you could be right and
maybe it is it is just you know somebody
just said there's money and they're
still gonna get a little bag you still
gonna get a cut that's what i was saying
like when people sit there and they're
like yo
you know
505 and microsoft got one over on them
okay five or five got one overall but
here's the thing but
here's what they know here's i hear
where y'all going and it could be very
rare which i said but y'all also have to
admit sony cares about their optics
they care about their exclusives and it
from uh from the marketing standpoint it
is not a good look
for them based on how they operate this
is the same company that we just talked
about last week who put stipulations
into block things to go to game pass
right so maybe in this case they knew
after the fact it's okay we don't care
at this point that we could do it is
what it is with this game but subsequent
games they they can subsequent games you
see them block or whatever but it's all
i would say it's a very
intriguing situation i think there's a
lot of this second party stuff like i
like for instance like all right
microsoft did funded to you know
whatever whatever part of tunic or
whatever tunic is coming to the
playstation next month right whatever
the case like things like that like it's
gonna happen i understand the kojima
thing is that's coaching playstation
right they own the ip and it just to me
it just really feels to me maybe there
is this other tier that they don't
really care about like like attic was
saying because it it is this thing where
you knew to me they knew exactly what's
going on and this idea of like we can't
do anything about it i i
when it came to baseball yes a hundred
percent because that is the game you
were making for the mlb yeah i'm gonna
be changed how they're thinking and
that's it
what but i don't know not this no i get
what you have what happens if it's if
it's deeper than we think yeah what if
it is
what happens if
during
during six seven months ago they
announced on twitter they buy an
activision and so he's like what we got
to do to make this right
listen i want this trading on pc game
pass
no but if you really if
to make it right isn't that i want this
training on console that's right that's
how you kind of but
if a realm like that exists which i
doubt it is that i think that's even
microsoft would know
something's too far
i mean it's like that that's why i feel
like if
if this went to console dane dating game
pass when it came to the xbox brand then
i would agree a hundred percent with
people you know they found a loophole
but the fact that it's a pc game pass
which they rebranded to right it's not
no longer xbox right pc game pass that's
why i feel like
sony doesn't feel intimidated by the pc
portion of the game perhaps
it's the console version the reason why
they don't feel intimidated by the pc
portion of the game pass because the pc
portion of game pass looks like the step
sister
so far
which doesn't
right now it doesn't make any sense
and that's only because steam is the
override fighting yeah
right it's the bigger entity so
game pass is looking at looking as
non-threatening in that space in that
space if if
what we're hearing
with the integration of game pass and
game pass pc
and steam
that stuff actually does happen or
something like that does happen that
changes the whole thought process to
that so okay yeah attic might be right
uh putting it in pc game passes
non-threatening just putting it over
there making some more money off of
these dudes because we made money off of
these dudes that's that's a good
possibility and i think the difference
came with the third party stuff that
they blocked from coming to game pass is
a they block it for coming to console
game pass i've never really seen them go
too much for the pc boys right and b
they don't fund these games they just
pay for them
for them to be marketing and stuff like
that they funded death stranded right
yeah so if they fall short or they're
not happy it's on them to cover that
money back i i still say i agree a lot i
still say though the fact that the block
is still on the console version of game
pass to me shows that they are in tune
with their brand and they're not going
to just let things run around so in this
case
yeah it's just either a
there was a loophole found by microsoft
and microsoft jumped at it the minute
they were able to that con contractually
that was able to end or b like you said
you got you and solve saying which is
like they looked at with the conscience
and then and let's be real in your
defense you know i don't know what death
stranding salesman but we have to admit
the investment what king is saying is
very high for that title you know kojima
when he come through
he come through the games be looking
nice they'd be you know what i'm saying
as far as the production value and that
they're doing
del toro is in there and this one and
that one and norman reena is walking
dead and it don't look like a cheap game
it's like that
it's like the
it's like
who's that carrot smokey from the
original friday he gets the he gets the
[ __ ] uh this the money from his
his mom the mom
is kojima
and he's smoking he can't say he takes a
dollar what's this what's this
like what's going on this isn't what i
gave you kojima listen
i mean the thing for me
my final point is just from the kojima
standpoint and you know
them you know you're gonna get a nice
little bag obviously you're gonna
benefit from it and i'm just i am
curious about death stranding two
pc stuff
how that's gonna work next next go
around if a sequel is funded and i am i
wanna see what's going on with his uh
xbox game only from the standpoint is
going to be utilizing cloud technology i
did hear for people who played deaf
shredding that there's some type of
mini version of a social interactive
part where you can leave things around
the map i heard or something like that
so to me and again i used to love kajima
back in the day i think he goes off
sometimes but i will give him this
there's a part of me when he makes
whatever this xbox game that's going to
use azure and cloud tech i want to see
how he utilized because he's an out of
the box thinker he maybe could do
something really cool with that game so
i expect like a rollout i expect
obviously they promoting this right now
you know we'll see what happens at the
game awards and what continues to happen
with the stuff that he's producing but
yeah look make no mistake i have to give
king
from an optic standpoint
it's hilarious and microsoft
pr and marketers did a phenomenal job in
doing they knew
the power of the zeitgeist with this
game saying that it's on their platform
in pc game pass or whatever so
what happens that's spider-man it's true
that's crazy if that uh wow i don't see
it the spider-man thing's true that at
that point sony's literally don't care
like they're like yeah as long as this
isn't on xbox about money yeah no i'm
saying like because i think they care
about the semantics they care about you
know the overall
aesthetics of the gaming industry how
they're looked at because that's the
reason they're so big on like reviews
but i don't think they care about the pc
market i think they're mainly focused on
the console market they want to sell
games on pc right but i don't think that
they have as much energy that they have
for the console industry in terms of the
console market that they do the pc
market i say this right okay and i know
uh chicago was about to say no
i say
wait to this generation is almost over
when they really know who did that for
you
and the flood
of triple a first party games that's
gonna hit game pass oh here we go and
you dudes are gonna be like
why are they doing that
so are you saying are you saying king
they're going to be like an e3 show and
microsoft's going to come up there and
they're going to have a nah
hold on they're going to have a g.o.w
pop up they're like gears of war
people's going to be screaming and then
you imply that pc game pass is the back
door that that that all these titles
could come through so despite it
what they do is this is this is how
conditioning happens
this is this is how conditioning happens
your husband tells you
uh every week oh okay i got to go to
this i got to do this every friday
i know where you're going every friday
he gotta go here so you get conditioned
to it because the first you fought you
fought it nah nah nah
you fought it you can't go here on
friday nah nah but he's doing that he's
going outside the house outside the
barrage on friday not telling you why
that's what you said and and then it
turned into every weekend you got
conditioned you got beat down you got
beat into submission
so right now is going to pc game pass
but then it's going to slow down right
that whole anger oh it's just pc game
pass it's not game pack and they all
going to be sliding over
and then once you already lubed and good
oh my god wow wow
that is gonna slide right in the game
you can't fight now because you already
gave up all that energy for pc game
passes you just gonna accept
regular game pass you accept it because
you accept it every year now mlp the
show is in game pass and there's nothing
you can do about it so you're making up
these weird things well mob did it and
sony didn't do it
sonny make it and you pay for it and we
get it for free so
i don't care
what exactly you make i'm gonna tell you
this
[Music]
180 billion dollars in debt
make you move different
make you think different when those debt
collectors is calling on the phone
you're calling other people like yo i
got to get this
and you're looking around like what the
can i sell what can i sell stuff gotta
go
i can leverage these ips i could get
some bread from here how much you think
we could get for that that's exactly
what they said when them when the bill
collected call on the phone and say you
owe us 40 billion
what we can get
on pc
what we can get this is a pawn shop okay
so so what they said was they already
have death stranded because he said yo
what what what can we get for definition
pc it's already on pc it ain't on pc
game pass
get it over there we can get some money
from them let's see your flight they do
okay
yeah that's right man that's a problem
uh problem so you're looking over you
like yo
let's shore this up they not pushing
consoles like that because y'all been
losing every month
you're not pushing consoles like that we
got that hold up in the shop so you're
not selling those so you're not making
money there you're trying to refabricate
and get the playstation 4s out they're
not buying
the fan base ain't buying so we got to
go to a place where the money good
money good on game pass pc
all i'm saying is 180 billion dollars in
debt
make you move different
and these dudes is moving wild yeah you
know
hey hey king you know why they did this
tell us
they got to pay for that bungee
acquisition oh my
[Laughter]
um
yeah i just it's gonna be just
definitely a funny situation on some
level definitely surprised it might be
the first podcast below three hours
let's not fix it right let's start
let's keep going
let's get these super chat
spoken to the question with the latest
claims by microsoft accusing sony of
playing paying blocking rights to
develop to keep games off game pass
which practice do you most align with
between the companies the winner of the
four-way ilp poll at 45
of the vote was the messi lords i don't
care they both playing dirty ain't
nobody got time for this but they try to
play on one console
coming in at second place at 27 percent
of the vote both practices are five by
me it's called competition in third
place very close 26 of the vote buying
publishers and permanently making most
of them exclusive to your subscription
service and in last place with not a
single vote
buying timed exclusive game releases and
secretly extending those deals from
other platforms while it remains in the
zeitgeist group shout out to all the
lords who participated just a heads up
i'm gonna be changing the format of the
poll i suggest i suspect some uh
manipulation
and um
yeah it will not be in the place it will
normally be i will announce where it
will be moving forward and i think the
guilty parties that are involved know
who they are
and yes the manipulation we will be
changing moving forward where the poll
will locate it i will make the
announcement later today on the iron
laws podcast
again so salute to that yeah oh look who
put his eye emojis up yes
of individuals i feel have definitely
got so we need to talk about the results
though the social manipulation yes you
could guess king you could talk about
the results yeah so he said yes
yeah another week where the messies is
out
yeah
something's going on so so the algorithm
um
we manipulated the algorithm to our
favor uh just like sony manipulates the
cash to block dudes
we ain't gonna snitch on them because we
don't snitch like that oh
[Laughter]
hashtag stop snitching okay
we all trying to game on one console so
let's quietly acquire these dudes
acquisition season you know our money
just devaluing in the bank so we might
as well you know pay for them uh get
those guys under our wings but yeah man
they're blocking stuff now not about
that i know it's okay
these dudes is uh doing things you know
in conjunction and and i say god bless
all fear is love and war yeah beyonce do
what you gotta do this is how you wanna
get down i understand there's
consequences and repercussions for your
actions
[Laughter]
background
ridiculous out here blocking we
acquiring let's keep going baby let's
keep going
with the pc game that's hilarious anyway
sorry
you hilarious i can't
anyway
can i buy a val king
yes yes you may yes you may you can buy
a value
and and the the value of that value is
equal to i'll take it i'm trying to go
to the gamepad
can i i think i think it's g-a-m
okay can i can i get a g can we solve
the puzzle
and move on
[Laughter]
i know what it is yes
yo give shout out to will be said vanna
white looking very rough today
shout out to our vanna white
man white hasn't shaved yeah that's the
old school reference shout out to the
legendary wilby hood good to see you
brother
anyway solving we caught up yes sir hold
on one second we got
five dollar super chat salute lords you
guys have been killing it love this show
by the way did you see the news about a
blade game from ubisoft so there's been
some excuses
i guess the blade director is is they
attach them to some motion capture stuff
so
we'll see
we'll see we got donald tackle five
dollar super chat if embracer just keeps
putting out golem level lord of the
rings games instead of shadow of mortal
level games the acquisition was a waste
yeah
i agree with you yeah gollum doesn't
look good but we haven't played it so we
don't know maddie cannot stand that guy
i like bob yeah i'll be talking about
speaker's voice hopefully it's in game
pass dandy
then we got general back five dollars
how do the embracer group escape all the
regulatory business that goes into
buying studios they grab they grab ish
every other week all hail the iop well
they don't have a console so they're not
beholden to that
yeah they're the distributor
they're gonna connect they connect
and all the things
the thing about it is the amount of
money that went into activision blizzard
doesn't compare to what they spend
yeah which is crazy somebody here y'all
please hit that like button please say
it for the kids for the chili hit the
like listen every time you hit the like
button the sony guy sheds more tests oh
my god
and i'm thirsty yo
i can't continue oh hold on i gotta
interrupt protocol one second song
because i did
miss out on some of them actually
continue i'll get the merch lined up you
go okay
yeah
what do you make of the spider-man
spider and the teaser image xbox put out
for death stranding
well it showed
on the pc hold on and it went to pc with
def stranded and soon death standing
with the game pass pc spider-man
certified let's go clarity
i heard i see we we we are frauds
because we have not played death
stranded and for the people who played
death stranded they say that that spider
is on the box part of it yeah part of
the joint so but we will see we will
it's part of the box and it's part of a
bigger
inception okay
all right so so so if we can't be
fragged like you say if we're unraveling
the conspiracy oh my lord continues
up continuing we got clutch man on one
two dollars whoa brad sam's that's what
i'm talking about yeah brad is awesome
brad was awesome then we got flame
remember for 23 months
these last few years have been seriously
boring thank god for all the
acquisitions
also i hate that xbox is wasting more
money on kojima wow
it's definitely a waste of money
there we go free on kelly five dollars
was that kang you cannot escape jim ryan
domination sony is dominating
okay dominating you
[Laughter]
yo that was crazy are you are you are
you applying that uh that he likes to be
uh whoa nominated
are you playing he he he he likes to be
directed towards his stuff
he likes to pay wow he likes to be
dominated by jim
i don't see it sir i mean i'm honestly
telling you you've been losing for the
past five months
i know it's really messed up but all i
can see is just like oh lord don't even
don't give up
a blurry vhs video somewhere out there
with this footage
you guys support he's probably
saying that they're dominating and they
aren't he told you they you are not
enough you you
you in the face and you said are you
outside cheating and he looked at you
you said kells you not enough
this is how this going man you know why
he's so
is so uh offensive to the stuff you say
that because he be getting told that in
the in the in the in the prison maybe he
said they're trying to sleep the ceo
baby touch the glass she said no
no i will not touch the glass
you're not enough i can't pay the bills
they put his hands to the bar and the
you know the hair come from they make
him put an xbox controller in his head
he's like you're gonna play greatness
this is like this is cormac
mccarthy-esque exposition
this man was dominated in prison anyway
moving on
is when he hears that that gate opened
at three in the morning he's like you
coming with me
xbox walk in
[Laughter]
xbox soap moving on from this smelly
dream
carol mack two dollar super that shout
out to lord addict's haircut yeah you
kind of fly today kind of fly no doubt
then we got big bad bow remember for 26
months thank you sir
we got free r kelly once again five
dollars
nobody cares about that stranding on
game pass lo lojima low team a bit
washed up keep that trash on game pass
with the mlb the show sony cleaning
house oh this is what it is
and what that translated into from
sony's hours thank you for your 75
[Laughter]
kelly stop trading cigs for super chat
money at the common sense no don't do
them like that
y'all invested y'all gotta leave that
man alone y'all are capped for death
stranding when it came out now it's
trash hypocrisy
you coming with me
[Laughter]
he got a whole xbox onesie
he's sitting in the d room with him
wow wow wow wow
why is all gamer remember for 25 months
and now that r kelly's in jail dot dot
dot and thanks to this news
thanks to this news i could now use my
steam deck to get my weekly golden
shower fix thank you game pass
the know there is a a urinating mechanic
we don't even need exposition contacts
moving on time
kids move remember for 27 months
xbox changed the name of the pc game
pass earlier this year sony doesn't have
an addendum for pc game pass
that's special means everything comes oh
my god
i think i'm gonna die from that one man
wow
then we gotta
mr blt's five dollar super chat to cogs
and kings point when spider-man when
spider-man's license is up for renewal
couldn't disney demand council parody
just like mlb no hmm
disney has nothing to do with spider-man
owns that character in its entirety yes
yep so that's why they have to put out a
game or move i mean a movie every three
years if they do not then the ip reverts
back to uh
marvel which is owned by disney
and then they can use them but
they will continue to put out this stuff
what they do not own spider-man is in
the cartoons and stuff like that that
could be put out in conjunction with
marvel yeah
that's why you see like in order to do
like finesse things like in the they'll
change stuff like comics to make it like
less accurate in the actual movies and
stuff
and we have a k johnson wait hold on we
got hard geek sydney five dollar super
chat i hate you
let me play with your joystick have you
availed of the offline profile
illuminati patreon level yet for some of
that one-on-one time up i already told
you
i don't know what patreon level you're
talking about because that does not
exist
you gotta make sure that year does not
exist we will make that popping and i
know that will be very very weird
saturday
i don't know man i i think that
algorithm is awesome
i know liz i know when you're here and
it's super chance that nobody's
different
moving
along okay
kay johnson two dollars from chat who
did that for you shout out to kate
johnson
thank you kay
wow then we got free r kelly two dollars
super chat kang happy to have jim ryan
sloppy
there's a mole in sony's ip lineup
then we have sogv five dollar super chat
loving the vids ayo king i'm gonna need
that new album vocal cords are
immaculate
no doubt
you're singing during the boxing world
yeah his boxing commentary had me that
chat king is wrong there is gonna be a
ps6 but it's gonna be a prototype and
the most expensive hardware in the world
love you guys
messi
yeah we got the xbox expansion pass two
dollar super chat thank you oh hold on
that's the ghost that's the girl oh slow
slow to the gold side
yeah it's been a minute let's see him in
a minute cheers to addict iop and my tlc
crew change.org
the ghost definitely initiated to change
that old movie whenever we disagree with
anything in gaming so we have to once if
game pass like teams
they don't mess with that other stuff
that's for the playstation
i haven't seen you on fortnight yet no
he'd be playing though yeah i haven't
seen him with me okay got something all
these chicken dinners but yeah get them
victory house so what's up man so he
just said never go full kojima oh okay
okay
you think i'm in bite-sized chunks
bite-sized
this isn't really this really isn't like
huge huge nudes but uh what apparently
some of the
regions are already starting to prove
the microsoft yeah someone in the chat
says saudi arabia approved
without
like here's the thing when i shoot
people
okay i'm semi okay at it i have semi
accuracy where i always misplace before
tonight is they build the empire state
building yeah i hate that
[Music]
pc game pass didn't exist when this game
and deal was made
no no one no one thought let alone sony
that a pc subscription service was
feasible or become successful yeah
that's fine
once it's out
you jump on that immediately
i don't i don't see them their lawyers
just you know resting on their laurels
on this i don't see this
yeah i'll show you i'll see they could
basically what you said is they could
have extended it to block if they chose
and they chose the moment that came out
you got to jump on that and if you're
not then you should get fired that's it
that's where you're going you're winning
me over slowly
heart get today ten dollars of a chat
disney slash marvel show coming in
september spider-man logo tease disney
announcing spider-man and miles coming
to pc game pass maybe question mark uh
some same odd situation here disney owns
the character uh
this is the almost a character meaning
that what real stake do they have in
this coming over to pc game pass we'll
see you'll see
let me see
and like alex said this from the
brightest sun to two euros super chat
saudi arabia has just approved the abk
deal
then we have fuzzy belvedere
two dollar super chat pc game pass this
is how you share a game yo
yo i know what you're doing i know what
you're doing fuzzy then we have drogba
five dollar super chat how much of the
rising cost of making games we think is
quote unquote real i.e wages production
versus bloated marketing and suppliers
uh i think prices they're raising prices
because they can't
no no inflation is real inflation is
ruined just the fact like when you think
about
what we expect of games now yeah
ridiculous bro it's ridiculous
but i also i will say that it is up to
the market to dictate
yeah and if the market dictates that
people spend that money and buy it and
they're getting away with it they're
going to keep doing it
not that i agree with it not after that
we said it like gamers we
very rarely really put our foot down
because when it's that fire heat gain
that we've been wanting dudes be better
than me quick it's just the fact that's
what i said
bigger and
there's more manpower uh people get paid
more now than they did in the past so if
you're paying somebody or groups on an
hourly wage or you're paying them
or even a salary salaries has gone up
you know cost of living has gone up so
you have to factor that into the time
and stuff that goes into making these
games with the developers
not to say that these engines are cheap
to make the sounds the licensees for
audio and stuff like that so excuse me
depending on what type of game you're
trying to make and where you're trying
to take it the cost is astronomical
yeah there's all these everybody's the
price has gone up i think
the
the biggest issue when it comes to that
is just like look like
you can disagree with the practice of
raising prices but still buy the games i
feel like
i feel like people think that you can't
do that like i don't agree with paying
ten dollars more for games
but it's like i said on on guys's
podcast you know what's worse than
paying 70 for god of war
not playing god war because i don't want
to pay 70 dollars like
they they got us
between a rock place and a hard place
like there's nothing you can do like
there's either there's stuff you could
do it's just you know the impulse but
realistically
it takes a huge movement to
realistically change stuff and you as an
individual you're better off probably
just
buying something you want to play
playing like because i don't
and you know it would be different if we
knew that certain things were going to
change like if something like that
happens we're not going to get like many
micro transactions or season passes will
go away
most likely these publishers are going
to still do all of that other stuff with
the 10 increase last time i checked 2k
didn't just drop all their stuff in in
my part
you still got to pay 10 dollars with all
that too
oh yeah gamers look they're just not
going to wait but i mean that's just how
i look at it sadly
when when the force of change comes from
another direction it has to be an entity
that is hungry enough and big enough to
force the change to happen oh yeah and
and we've seen it already so the fact
that one of the entities that from from
a standpoint of loss
changed how subscription services is
the game pass would not be successful in
fact how it is right now without first
party day and date inside the game pass
that
diametrically changed how we saw
everything very dynamic in that view
sony is going to have to acquiesce
right it's going to have to happen
either get down and lay down so
that's 70 if you guys do not buy god of
war day one or whatever and y'all do too
like you've been doing waiting for a
sale or trying to get it on a break
like that because
you guys are the instrument of your own
demise y'all built this monster not a
monster is capitalizing and dominating
you so what you want is from this
monster is to to actually copy what the
the competitor is doing
so
y'all continue down the path that you're
doing because you don't buy games anyway
and you will see once xbox game pass
continues to grow in this fashion your
games will be dating day two so that
will happen change will happen it will
change
all i know is there's way worse
scenarios that can happen than you pay
an extra ten dollars a
poor game you could be in a jail cell
with kelly oh god saw it too in the
morning
moving on
yo could you imagine the people that
tune in that don't know don't know the
context of what we're talking about
exactly don't know that yeah
exactly
the spider on the box is actually from
distracting you don't believe the
spider-man yes so you say that's what
you said
oh there you guys he likes the other way
we have called weeb five dollars
there will be a ps6 it will just be the
luna ps6 after amazon acquires sony
entirely tell the truth
hector the macho man five dollar super
chat oh hell the lords king is 97 right
and the ps6 might not come i love the
fact that all the sony ponies woke up
with haihachi faces
yo i gotta say thank you hector and um
your game coffee talk is inside game
pass
and uh i just i just wanted to let them
know no doubt moving on right we got
flame two dollar super chat this is a
witch hunt hashtag messy lords forever i
know some evidence pointing your way
flame i don't know
the film
worry about explaining we're fine but
you're definitely a suspect
in the investigation you're a suspect
then we got cw two dollars with the chat
hashtag just one
dot dot more snatch up for xbox
wow
the lead
we got slow mo back slap five dollars
for further proof how kojima gets away
with anything he has a character in
death stranding called die hard man what
if i made one called pass gas man wow
yeah messy yeah i'm gonna try to play
that again on my steam deck as a habit
on there i just installed it i'm gonna
give it a shot but yeah i mean it's like
a shout out to bg because b i love what
he says fake deep
fake beep
that's what he loves
all right then we have did it oh no i
got jumped my goodness there's a lot of
super chats today
yeah we got i got jumping back give me a
second see all right so you said no damn
we had a lot holy damn we still got to i
hate we're trying to get out of here
about four guys i know we would do it
good okay
okay i got it okay i got it i got it
texas yeah texas five dollar super chat
it appears saudi arabia has approved
microsoft activision blizzard hit the
like and praise the lord yes salute
okay then we have
gaming for today remember for 33 months
glad my game pass brethren can try this
technical feat of balancing packages on
their backs actually i'm really not and
as always hey king boo-boo
then we have
lord lord metroid 2 super chat let r
kelly have his jim ryan visits okay wow
starting this attic and king stuff again
then we have maybe that's why the the
ceos are saying two in the morning
it's messy did we have absolute sword
two dollar super chat
jimmy said let's try the other hole this
time
time on these super chats jesus
the lords they remember the lord's day
well it's nothing sacred language oh my
god
we got black roman people for 16 months
great show as always bs was spitting
saudi arabia starting the coming domino
effect phil next year should tweet out
domino [ __ ] when this close wow
bessie no not dominique i screamed my
copy cool
wow
the table
remember that yes that's old school
that's old school
what's going on
i used to love those old dudes i don't
know all the steps
in front of the world
then we got akw five pound super chat
saturday night with saab i'm up for that
no you not whoa
are you up for that
he's definitely up for that there it is
we're gonna make that to 25
that's it for
saturday night
you know you you get a half an hour with
the man wow
wow
you get a half an hour with the man the
myth the legend wow um
i'll make sure i get off camera next
time
to see my wife up
god forbid
good to you
so now that roe versus wade has been
overturned i guess sony is dumping all
their illegitimate on game fast now
let's see this is this is what i wanted
to see on friday
july mpd over microsoft king
right now
they did yeah
ah i didn't hear about it just like a
animal dying in the woods nobody cares
what you must say today
beat y'all a month oh and when the
series asked me to troll them off the
world take notice but when y'all do
anything nobody can oh
messy
send me the facts stop giving me your
lips
every heartbeat sadie disagree on the
idea that you should keep buying at 70
if you don't like it you don't find drug
addiction by becoming an addict no pun
intended
uh to change things you you have to not
participate that is true
the thing is though is first off like
we
are you just not going to not play games
like how half the publishers are making
70 games like are we just not gonna play
any new games like imagine when xbox
sooner or later hits the 70 title which
is not gonna play those games i'll be
playing the hell out of them in game
pass yeah i get that but he's playing
the hell out of them
it's just like you know when god of war
ragnarok comes out i'm not gonna let ten
dollars stop me from enjoying a game
it's just not gonna happen so you know i
i will suggest you know be more
selective just don't buy anything now
and what's funny is is people will sit
there and they will buy every game known
to man for 60 bucks
every game knowing
damn well they ain't going to play half
of those games
and then they want to complain that i
say yo i don't and i said i don't agree
with it okay but i also said i'm not
going to let it stop me from playing
games well yeah that's your part that's
a personal choice
be honest with you i don't care if y'all
ever buy a game but the thing is don't
complain about it either buy it or don't
that's it vote with your wallet do it
stand on your conviction like for me
last of us was what i wanted last of us
remastered so bad but i was just like i
didn't feel that value for that price
point so i'm going to wait you know yeah
and i'm not getting it either it's like
look like this is not like an all game
thing like some games aren't even 70
dollars it's like the games that are
really important to you get those games
but the games that you're on the fence
with now it's an extra ten dollars that
ten dollars could be the deciding factor
it's like look i would have bought it
for sixty but seventy i ain't messing
with this game that much to buy that
game i wouldn't
an hour in you know i wasn't in the
right
he wasn't the right thing
i guess i guess that that's my biggest
thing it's just like do we waste so much
money on games we don't play any what no
i get it but it to hard
i do understand you know the mindset you
know the people you know wanting to take
a stand on it and saying you know
they're not doing but see the thing is i
never told them not to take a stand i
feel like you talking about i just told
i just told them don't expect me to pick
up the pictures
it's like one of those things where it's
like you know you're doing the strike at
work i need that money going away
they're walking past people
and then guess what like you know we're
gonna sit there you guys gonna boycott
outside the outside the business i'm
gonna come out friday with my paycheck
in my hands
i needed this i got this now you can do
that
that man got his
as long as neither parties or trying to
tell the other party not to do it i
don't see anything
i hear you there i hate it like let
people do what they want to do like i'm
firmly if you want to be a scab go to
school
there is a thing where it's like i'm a
content creator i'm a podcaster like it
goes deeper than just the money it goes
to coverage
it's your personal choice when you do
how you want to do don't let no one move
you off yourself no i mean i i would
just i would just say explain it okay
like he's super chatty he's super
chatted too
he's super chatted
for that discussion and i gave him that
discussion
moving on
hold on diggle big thickets up there
yeah man i'm right there hold on it's
like a man
oh my god
uh yo did my man say let all kelly have
jim ryan conjugal business come on
that's hitting below the boat though i
hear most sony guys like it wow
jesus yeah that's the thing
disrespectful
i thought we was gonna get through this
[ __ ] it's highly difficult there we go
saudi arabia first to approve activision
blizzard king domino's falling
yeah here we go listen
it's going to happen
then we have bbw bobby
super chat
bbw bobby outside
we're not going to act like death
stranding a game of the generation xbox
slash pc players should be lucky to be
able to touch greatness on their minimal
budget
bobby schmertz outside yeah bobby you
love those big girls hey big bobby
thank you for supporting now we're gonna
get it for free cause you like to pay
for that stuff you pay like you wait
bobby
yo
okay shout out to beautiful
moving
on
let me see hold on a second the wise old
gamer five dollars look at that jim to r
kelly when i say boop boop you say beat
me
wow
wow this is what i wanted see this is
what i wanted wow
that was messy
what else she got
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
you know it's crazy about bobby king
that that's our kelly's cellmate yo
right now go bobby
you know what's funny when the ceo comes
against our kelly man bobby like why
can't i go
you got to find that picture of that
video of our busy dancing oh you like
this and the hat doesn't come off
right now
my boys
70 games is a wait for price drop or
sale the high seas until it's cheap and
then buy yeah
can't go set you up
thank you so um playstation pc launcher
a reference has been discovered in
spider-man pc this is following the um
the discovery of references to psn
account linking shout out to video games
chronicle this is so they could soon
introduce its own launcher for pc games
following the footsteps of ubisoft
rockstar and activision blizzard
references to a playstation pc launcher
have been found within the files of
marvel spider-man remastered which
launched on pc last week suggesting that
such a platform could be in sony's
future plans
king you are all over this
what did you say about this what's your
thoughts on this
monkey see monkey do
monkey do it all the time
every time
microsoft does something or somebody
does something successful and you're
supposed to this is a copycat business
i knew this was coming once they said
that they don't have the ability to show
you your platinums and your stuff now
this was coming so dude is laughing at
me
they're not gonna have us pay for
nothing yo
guarantee you you're gonna have a
separate subscription service
to this
it ain't gonna be all-encompassing it
ain't gonna be like game pass ultimate
where you got game pass ultimate pc you
get game pass you know it's not going to
be like that
it's not going to be like that they're
going to have a separate joint
because remember they look at the pc
entity
as a separate entity
it's not it's not overhead so when
somebody has said do i have to buy this
game
on if i have it on pc and it's a
playstation game do i have to buy it
again for my playstation if i want to
play it over there and they was like
yeah
you know it's a separate entity sir this
is not connected and this is the reason
why so you imply that the pc launcher is
going to be separate from this oh yes
it's going to be completely separate
they are going to have to pony up
because
listen we found out today that they like
to be dominated
why we found out today
kells told us
yeah being that kells is the
representative
and he represents
the playstation nation
he definitely told us that they like to
pay remember and then bobby came in and
reiterated it
and you know bob bobby said bobby said
we need
you know what's funny king you have like
bobby and r kelly arguing who's gonna
pay more i'll pay a hundred yo
yo
if they fight to pay more but it doesn't
ever translate to actual sales
so they do a lot of conversating and
and and
stuff never really happens and it never
really comes to fruition but what i do
say is sony is gonna do the launcher
that's inevitable this i knew this stuff
was coming uh they my question to the
team is is it going to be a separate
entity or do you think it's going to be
integrated into playstation plus now
premium service whatever they got going
over there do you think they added extra
tier do they roll that into the premium
tier how do you think they get the pc
launcher if if it's not separate
integrated into the uh the playstation
service addict
your thoughts on this playstation pc
live
yeah pc connoisseur you're the lord of
pc the lord of showing us your bills
let's go
i i look
unless it's day and date i don't care i
i really don't because i'm not good like
if a game i'm enjoying in a game i want
to play
comes out two years later on pc i've
already beat it i've already moved on
with my life man like you know i don't
need to play
spider-man two years ago now like i
played it two years ago right like and
that's why you know the pc master race
they wait and race
buy a playstation you want to play buy
playstation you want to play certain
things by the platform it comes on so
you never like see me on here i might
ask for it and hope it comes to a
platform
but i understand at the end of the day
like look like sometimes you gotta call
you got to spend money to get stuff
and i it's just me personally what if
they're willing to wait though honey
what if they will wait okay
i don't care you can wait like you can
get a sport 100 times on twitter you can
go on on youtube and see thumbnails
spoiling the last boss do that that's
you that's cute but ain't me
oh you couldn't catch me like that
i'm a player out there like that no
because then those that's the kind of
person that way six months that they're
you in a conversation about a game
they're like i ain't played it yet okay
so
like no like you could say you're wait
six months and you just sit there and be
like here oh
cause it's just like look like you if
you were serious about playing that game
guess what you had played it you weren't
yeah it was something that it was
it was
so did addict play finally oh slow
morning pass back the race is upset
so what you're saying is people that got
morals to hell with your morals and
standing on your
not saying that you don't have morals
what i'm saying is they have their
morals because my morals for this final
fantasy you said it was multiple i'm
waiting for it i'm like giving you that
bread
right so when it comes to but i play
final fantasy gonna do that no he's
talking about his personal choice no no
i don't care about your choice yeah i
know exactly what i'm saying is what if
this is the argument the person comes to
you and be like but i have more rules
and then i gotta stand on this squad
okay and your morals are stopping you
from a good experience that's you that's
you probably not a meat brother
it's not a problem it doesn't matter if
it's a good or a bad experience is the
fact that it's they're standing on a
square because they're looking for that
change it's a small ass square that's
what i'm seeing i'm on my pinky toe
pieces are starting to pick up with
these games
they're better they better yeah it's
just
easier it's like look like final fantasy
7
rebirth rebuilds i don't know what that
game's called i'm gonna be playing that
on the ps5 okay i'm not waiting a year
to play on the pieces
i respect people that do wait it just
couldn't be me i think it's it's just
not what you want to do i'll respect
that yeah
mm-hmm
where are we at
that was it okay
when's the last time like i said
anything about like i don't buy games on
pc like they they they unless this
unless they put their own like game pass
pc maybe we can have a conversation oh
it would have to go with like the stuff
i already paid for because like right
now like ultimate if i want to play a
game on pc i have option of that because
i already paid for service that gives me
the option for that but i have not paid
for any of their games on pc not uh not
um not god of war not horizon
the question is
how do they integrate it do you think
separated or do you think it's going to
be
or is it going to be a separate entity
i think it'll be a separate entity
that's if they do something like i think
there's a good chance that they make
their own store
i'm just curious that they rip it from
steam that's what i'm working for i
don't think they would no they can't but
i don't think they can
i don't but then again god like they
have some very prominent titles some
very high demand titles
if
the only way i could see that working is
that they did date
because then they would feel like
if you want to play god of war on pc
you gonna have to come over here and
play
what about if they do day and date cross
buy
oh i don't think sony would do that
because they're gonna want you to buy on
playstation and pc
and with with the launcher you get all
that you get your trophies and cross
integration stage what's up what's up
so people are saying the contract what
am i contradicting you know you guys got
to hold that l tell me what i'm
contradicting we'll get back to that uh
what was you saying about what if the
playstation launcher that's ruben that
happened
has is that's their way into day and
date and they like all right you want it
on steam you pay whatever but if you buy
here and i want you you get day and date
with playstation and you get your
trophies your cross production that
would be interesting because then what
they can do is they can say look
you steam
fanboys
you know this is the same people that
condemn the switch but will pick up a
steam deck and act like there's nothing
wrong with that
um
you guys could still get your
your crap you know that's fine you can
still have that steam library
uh but if you want these day and date
you have to come over to our service
yeah i
i just don't know if they're willing to
jump out the window because once you
open up that door and jump out you can't
just go back but
i feel what you said i think i'm talking
to you
and i do feel like they're not ready to
make that commitment
maybe in the future
but i don't know if they're ready to
make that commitment but i don't see
them
opening up a service when they're when
they know steam is the big fish oh it's
fine it's literally data mined it's
literally in the cold there it is yeah
but we've seen games on destiny where
stuff was was originally put into the
system and took out at the last minute
like there's a lot of scenarios that
goes into that where it's you know the
code is there but they never intend on
using and they didn't take it fully and
another call from nix's psn account link
psn link entitlement but we see we see
that with but here's the thing like we
see that with minecraft right now you
know you buy minecraft on a variety of
services you buy anything on xbox on a
variety services you buy minecraft on
playstation you have to log in to the ps
to the xbox to even access it so i mean
that could literally just be that where
it's you know we got these games as a
service coming out with my ex
playstation and they want to make sure
that you're on their server even if
you're on pc
is is interesting uh king i mean should
we solve your thoughts
yeah i think it's happening i think it's
happening because at the end of the day
i i don't think they pull it off of any
other any other platform just because
they realized the reach
of
of steam they realized the growing reach
of egs even though it was like you know
ets had a hard time and i think this
specifically why they don't pull it off
of anybody else
pc gamers are fickle bro they're funny
like to this day you have people online
arguing that they'll never buy a game on
epic or epic stories facts they don't
like them launched
they don't like other launchers but they
steve that's
but at the same time if they do put out
their own launcher that's a hundred
percent profit for them they don't have
to share with anybody
and there and if on the back end if
there really is an issue with them
integrating all their trophy stuff and
all of their psn profile stuff into
other services this is the way around
there so okay
you get the game on ours right and you
get all everything all the perks you
expect from the play from having a psn
account
you get it if you purchase it on this
one
i feel like the only possible scenario
like here's the thing though
i think they've seen
ea try it fail leaving steam doing their
own thing they've seen ubisoft tried to
a point now i didn't say ubisoft failed
they still have their own little
subscription service uh they see
bethesda will even come back with their
own launcher mm-hmm and maybe that was a
little bit on microsoft's end but uh to
me i feel like there's too much
one thing you could say about the steam
fanboys
is they're not
budgies
they're not budging like they don't hold
it down stay on that square until that
score is demolished in the house
to the point where they will purchase
uh at least an xbox you know the xbox
version of a game paid version as
opposed to some type of subscription
that's why i feel like
sony
gotta see that and sometimes they make
dumb decisions so that this might just
be a dumb decision but it's just like i
don't see you selling unless you're on
steam it's just being realistic with the
matter like right i think the only way
that you could compete with steam
on some form of level and it would never
happen follow the console manufacturers
release games on steam on their own
platform right on pc like a console but
a store on pc like even nintendo
microsoft xbox they would have to come
together like ultron
and sell on that store and i never see
something like that happening so it's
just like look like if you want to sell
stuff on pc you don't have to
you know not make your own platform but
you have to keep your stuff on steam or
i don't see the point of doing it
i think they do everything i think
they're going to do it all they're going
to they're going to try to have their
cake and eat it too to king's point i
think it does go into that that that ps
plus thing because that top tier of ps
plus pfts
it is not popping off with what it has
right now
nothing gotta happen there's no there's
no real value as somebody who loves
having access to the older games and
stuff like that that is cool they have
shown a reluctance to put anything into
that but they're making you pay more for
it like
i don't think they even if for this new
set of games coming in this this coming
month they didn't announce anything for
that premium tier it's like i said it's
like i said
he came back
no i just want to point out like when
that service was originally
when that service was originally put
into place i always said that last year
felt like it was missing something it's
missing something right yes missing
games
[Laughter]
but they say game pass they got games
buddy if you don't look inside your
cabinet
it's beer it's empty it's not like woody
woodpecker remember woody woodpecker
open the refrigerator and starvation was
looking good
will they raise that price again for
that top tier if they do that
um well what do y'all think what do you
think about the idea of it of them doing
you know crossed by
one
you get another version you get the
pitches
so sony will shut down their business
before they do that
bro it's like you said you the writing's
on your own game pass before that
happened which i just said yeah you just
said they have to acquiesce
yeah
see here's the thing though here's the
thing though we know
sony about free stuff that's why you got
to pay the ps5 tax
that's why
you know even if you just bought
something they they want their money
it's not like this this persona 5 this
new ps5 edition with all the upgrades
and stuff that you got to buy that like
separately there's no upgrade to that so
it's just like you know in a way that
might be a new game i'm not completely
100 with the the details on that game
like
sony knows that people will pay and
sure i would agree if you saw but we
don't have
enough examples of them being generous
like that yeah
being pro-consumers
purchased the game that he had door
slammed behind them now we got them
as soon as they get their playstation oh
thank you i got my playstation 5
you know what it is king can they shut
that door and they shut that door and
they're like you got to go the long way
through and they try to open the other
it's locked oh you got to purchase this
key then they purchased that key to
unlock the door and walk in the room
it's like though there's there's there's
four doors how am i supposed to get out
we got keys though we got keys you can
dominate him
you said that yo yo
king sony is low-key putting all their
consumers in an escape room and asking
them
[Laughter]
i can't anyway
look this was interesting you know the
the tea leaves keep adding up to me you
know one lad the week before was the the
uh what is it the psa account linking we
found
um this week it's the references
you know shout out to nexus you know
saying they're outside oh that's my
heart you did not even know who they
were
yeah but i do know them now i mean
do you know your wife when you walk down
the
street what she does is it was it was
love at first i knew when i heard that i
was like next i heard that name before
and it was like oh there was 10 toes
down
there was a time i didn't know final
fantasy now i love final fantasy you
never know who you're going to fall in
love with
i can't wait not until they walk through
that door
justify when they when they did that
spider-man
there's a time we weren't doing iop but
we definitely do it now you know
every day
what what
what did brad sam said mm-hmm
do something different when are you
gonna do something for the first time
mm-hmm for the first time i fell in love
with nixon yeah okay moving on yeah i
didn't even know who they who nixon was
but we're going to let you out well we
know them now
and you you will learn to fail
anyway yeah go quiet and carry a big
stick
moving on oh yeah look this is this to
me there's enough evidence this this is
where it's going as far as i'm concerned
like you know it makes sense i agree
with solve that on probably
a playstation premium tier the question
is going to be if the launcher is going
to
say nickel and dime but get make you pay
a separate cost for that that's going to
be interesting i do think
that
it makes sense for them to listen i
don't they know
they can't compete with steam you know
what i'm saying head up like that i feel
that's why nexus exists nexus is there
to put it on steam steam is the number
one platform so you're not gonna get
away from that i just think i agree with
saul i think this is just havo let's add
this additional option where we control
this part here and give people the
option to say yo if you want to come in
if you want your trophies if you want
your potential cross save or whatever
you could get it here with us they're
gonna try to get
i was gonna say i think if anything
they're making this for their
free-to-play games
they're gonna put everything off about
to say because
if you are trying to do live service you
got 10 live service games
the days of locking it to just the
playstation ecosystem makes no sense
it makes no sense the whole game live
service exists on that cross play and
that engagement you want that's why
to king's point they bent the knee to
bungee on that initiative because it you
you you're cutting your nose just you
know despite your face like you you it
doesn't make any sense where you have a
game that requires multiplayer online
population active users and engagement
to say i'm locking this down to make
this exclusively
so what you're saying is in hindsight
yeah it's sony for the streets well
definitely live service games for the
streets we've we've already seen that we
that there's no even disputing your
point there like we all we saw the
budget he was like wow like we were
scared like yo that's gonna be exclusive
and they're like nope it's everything as
it is and that's like oh like this is
different because of that initiative and
let's be honest look at the mpd right
now you know what blew me away solve
what's that multiverses versus one npd
it's a free-to-play game it's a dope
game though i i'm but i'm saying so but
sony's banking on let's say they would i
don't know
but what if microsoft just runs over and
buys wb changes
yeah whatever i'm just saying like yeah
i know i saw a sony strategy and look it
makes sense and then you're gonna want
it
on pc where you could control it
right and you'd be like yo jump in our
launcher you get up in here go connect
your psc account you like your platinums
bro yes right and what if okay so i love
where you're going with this let's go
what if they don't give steam the
integration that could be just
all right but that'll be
that'll be the reason why that'll be the
reason why you have to get it here right
that's the end date that worked but
here's the thing though they getting a
nice bag with these games
but we're just not going to give you
what is exclusive to our ego
break it down break it down to help me
understand that and because and because
steam is such is such a big entity they
won't care mm-hmm
they won't care so wait y'all but y'all
saying to lock it away from steam on the
on
okay
that's right
my integration
and their launcher and then the the the
steam joint it's just a stage it's just
a speeding joint yeah you jump in wild i
think cowboy profile
i think there's a good chance
okay good i think there's a good chance
that they're free to play model games
but yeah it won't be on steam
because that's that baseball but here's
the thing though users they all see the
thieves going crazy they're going all
these right actual action a lot of
games that are very popular in like
terms of like a games as a service
the most popular ones aren't on steam
what are it true
overwatch on another platform you have
fortnite fall guys which is epic both of
those is epic epic tends to tie
themselves to the biggest games and try
to force you over there
those type of games
can survive off of steam because they
slowly build a community that's never
going to leave you're getting out of
there popping popping for that
i mean they
hopefully their games are popular
that's the next level like remember
fortnight is literally a paradigm shift
once in a generation
there's a difference between splitting
uh uh giving steam 30 on a game and
giving steam 30 percent on micro
transactions
and i think that their mindset will be
it's best to take the slow run where we
get more money in the end if our games
actually perform well
then give steve 30 here going on out
it's a good question it's a good
question to see if live service control
them valuing that over the raw active
users of a steam and cabinet still be
everywhere it is a good debate i don't
see it at the onset i mean i see if
if they have games that are successful
like that sure i could see them changing
up me like now we out of here i can see
that um and we're getting all of this
profit at the start though nah yeah i
don't think they're strong enough to
even challenge steam like that right now
yeah but later on we'll see no it's a
good it's a good discussion it's a good
discussion but yeah that's pretty much
what i got on that i will say this is
this is sony we're talking about this is
this is they they feel sometimes they
get a little bit too
okay steen gonna bend to i will like at
first it was microsoft's turn to try to
make steve into their will epic is still
at a war with them you know maybe now
they feel like so sony that guy yeah
shout out to slo-mo yeah he said big
publishers with a great ip could survive
without steam valerie has never been
honest look you guys are making good
points i'm not the point is is we don't
know if these titles are going to result
right that's all i'm saying i'm just
saying this the title that they gonna do
it better be banging back and b better
be one of them
for you to get out your face and be like
yo you you gotta pump over here holy if
you're saying i gotta say so sorry about
this
true and look at what multi-version sony
about to shoot 10 blanks
you better you back
attic you extra messy today it's highly
possible that they unleash all the
bullets and they hit nothing
but the odds on that
budget
very very low
because it because of the groups that's
involved yeah they got good challenges
right that that part right there so i
honestly believe one of those one of
them should hit
should hit somewhere and it doesn't have
to be fortnite we got to stop saying
yeah four nine's next night or call of
duty great
it has to be sustainable to the point
that it actually has a fan base that's
concurrent absolutely at this point you
know the only thing that could shut down
fortnite is literally epic going over
there and hitting the turn off for
tonight but you gotta make something
else it's like when we had jason rubin
it's like sometimes it's not about he
made a great point where it's not about
trying to directly compete you know i'm
gonna take out you know
find the niche
and
good point that nobody's doing create
your own thing and it's it's own
separate thing and then it becomes what
it becomes and then you control that
that'll be fine the last thing i wanted
to say before i forget is if this psn
account stuff is good which is dope
because i want trophies i want platinum
i want all that integration i want to
say because that's my only thing now
playing the steam version of like god of
war like damn you ain't got your save
data you know what i'm saying like that
sucks that's the only thing i care about
i don't care about
trophies and they save data i want the
progression that's what i love but the
thing i want to be clear
is
if you log into your ps4 account and all
that i hope it's at a situation where
you got to be online with a launcher
like they i need offline play also i'm
trying to get that steam deck popping
over there so you know
i'm trying to take that on the plane so
if you're launcher let me install it
after the one time connect my psn my
xbox 360 lover king profile you know
then it's that's it then when i launch
it
i won't be able to rock i don't want it
to be doing a check
they have to play that nice with like
i don't trust the security
it's not even just that like do you guys
think that
because right now they're being very
friendly with the steam deck but if they
made their own like laundry you think
they would make it compatible because
they have like a huge issue in the past
with like handhelds like pirating the
hell out of they stopped i mean the
thing that surprised me is it's all we
can speak to it is so does nexus is
outside we're making these things it's a
steam deck compatible
verified off the rip and it runs the
race you know what i'm saying and the
last part i said you know what's
surprising okay
why they didn't
do a deal with epic since they had the
relationship with unreal engine five i
thought those two would play nicer and
do something together yeah
they're getting money from them they're
investing in a space yeah that's that's
all that is they see where epic is going
you know what epic is is going through
so
something happened with that deal with
the bending of the knee and the cross
play something something went on there
yeah they had those conversations right
because that happened around the same
around the time that that stuff happened
so something went on there
but
sony wants money yeah they want their
own situation right you know you can
look over at microsoft and you can say
they they have a good blueprint in front
of them
right
game pass then pc game pass
you understand and
they can see how okay we can take this
from it we can do this from it we can
make this happen
and that's right don't give
your achievements and stuff like that to
steam already don't do that yeah because
that takes away the attractiveness you
know
yeah from your joint when you have plans
to do this
they don't own their own service
right so
that's a little bit of a of a roadblock
for them so they have to work around
stuff
they have to bring it to these dudes can
the service that we do have right now
can it hold up with this and they say
okay good let's work with this i think
that's why it's taking so long for
playstation pc launcher to come
to fruition because they do have to give
all that information over to microsoft
to work with the servers and to see if
this is going to work and it's going to
be integrated properly right over so i
mean because at the end of the day you
know they are working for us you know so
you know
you know what they're working for right
yeah
they actually give us money and we work
for them so you know they they're using
our facility for
to help you guys out so if we ever
wanted to really shut you down
you know uh i know what you do i know
what you're doing
yeah listen i mean the thing i thought
was interesting on
you know we got that
what about they also wanted to because i
think if you're going to do a launcher
you better have stuff ready right so
what if you wait in for one of the live
service joints to just to be on deck and
then you can be like bam you know what
i'm saying this new joint or whatever
but it'll be interesting they've got
enough content in it to put the pc thing
just if it's an additive yeah it's good
if it's a standalone
then you're gonna have to do day and
date
well yeah maybe day and date
is the p okay game all right check it
out right now here's a wild theory
i always said ragnarok is going to be
day and day
always said it
what if they released the pc portion of
the playstation launch
before god of war
to put god of war day and date on pc not
inside the playstation in the launcher
but inside the pc launcher to give the
pc
launcher some legs you make it sexy
there that adds more you're going back
you gonna make steve wait
you to thank me you got to wait because
it's in it's not launching on your you
got to wait
but i'm not saying that you're not going
to get it you're going to make them wait
are you long you're going to mix the
weight okay six to eight months
like you've been
that's a good point you can wait six to
eight months but it's gonna be in our
launcher and this is we're getting
that's how you make your launches sexy
yeah you're right
you're right so so the pc dudes are like
what is over here yes force them to go
over there if you want to play it that's
how you pull your
the crowd over can you might be doing i
might have to get you premium balls on
this one you might be on to something
and then you still sell it without
putting it inside your service on on the
playstation um side you still sell the
game so you're still getting the pc
sales at the same time you're still
getting the um the the playstation sales
and then after that six months when you
do it inside six to eight months when
you throw it aside steam then you throw
it on your your playstation services
premium drink you throw it in there so
you're gonna get that pc money over
there and you're gonna get those uh
reoccurring dudes over here on the
service joint so that's how you keep
that money flowing they're in the
business of making cash
so this ain't nobody nobody's feelings
and stuff like that this is about making
yourself viable for the future and in
this digital future
they have to be viable and i see that
happening just like that and if you ever
sony need help just holler
but i'll show you how to do it i'm
trying to do this son
look oh man shout out to uh hockey city
if they launched ragnarok day and day at
60 in the launcher i'd buy it on pc sony
launcher look
hey it is what it is
with the azure service what's up
the funny thing is
i already have a blue so that's my
playstation
this is the most messiest i have ever
seen
in like months
you would have been this is the new
haircut yeah the new haircut got him
acting different the new haircut has
released him yeah yeah he free to be
messy but look that's all i got great
discussion with the lords wrap this
thing up let's get this poll and then
sorry queue up the chats right you got
to translate it all right so do ilp poll
which will be in a new place
moving forward
with the recent acquisitions of major
game developers and publishers in the
last few years who do you perceive as
the biggest threat to the overall
consolidation of the games industry the
choices are a
embracer group
b
microsoft
c
tencent
or d i don't care nintendo's still
number one and they outside salute to
everybody that is rocking it out yes
flame i'm emphasizing a new place
for
the pole
i like that you caught that very
perceptive sir please rock that iop
phones when it goes up in its new place
and uh yeah so let's get there's a civil
chance all right we got raiden blade two
pound super chat imagine next year's god
of war two game pac god award two to
game past pc knows how he says next
year's god award
put it in xbox
then we have akw five pound super chat
what is happening today on this podcast
but i'm here for it hit that like button
the best messy this one
god tia levels messy there we go you
know what king you know what's funny
the fact that cog and saul be so messy
and we get the broad bottle
yeah it was so that was so horrible i
don't know
i know the blame is so misdirected
we should go on strike until we're
treated fairly here
they got controlled messi
[Music]
then we got hold on a second we got hard
to knee two dollars super chat game pass
ultimate three global whoever got the
code thank you to heart awesome a little
bit all right
give it to the community
oh there we go
again five dollar super chat some sony
love okay spider-man steam glow
so whoever got these codes shout out to
you give a big shout out to you sydney
you're always right
that's right your pc can show us your
bill that's the loot we like that that's
right let me see you playing with it
appreciate it
they
appreciate it argue the uh the pc people
need all the help they need
jesus
then we got spartan goes 17 two pounds
super chat playstation getting the bbl
whoa
where is ja rule
whoa
whoa
brazilian
wow time
[Applause]
sony don't have enough games to support
a launcher
that's why you're supposed to do day and
day
then we got drive by joe that's my five
dollars
it's missing the other 30 minutes of my
game trial on ps plus yes ps plus plus
premium whatever is missing a whole lot
then we got flame two dollar super chat
this is a great episode fellas
wow i don't know
oh wow you can put them in the hole
we have thx 1138 five dollar super chat
i believe sony will definitely put
cross-platform progress as part of ps
plus premium tier alliteration there
this gen sony ain't giving out free
meals at the soup kitchen
that's what king belize yeah
then we got todd couch five dollar super
chat thank y'all brothers for reminding
me that someone with a full-time job
family and kids can still love games
love this show gamer tag is rpg couch oh
salute
yeah we look for that man much love
brother i really really appreciate the
couch
no doubt
we got gamer by choice two dollars to
attack
him the game yeah he'd do what he want
do we know what server sony is using for
the games as a service game i mean it
should be azure yes we know y'all
you're damn well it was actually
though
they're using guy kai for that
they don't even talk to that dude no
more
[Laughter]
let's go
okay then we have texas two dollars
super chat sony's pc launcher in 2023
when god of war ragnarok actually drops
oh oh
okay
he said he's supposed to say holy
autocorrect sucks oh oh holy oh okay so
excuse me i just i think this hole
there live on friday raid y'all can we
have any space left in the clan oh right
now before 100 but
i'm taking the tickets about it all
right well i'm gonna take a ten is
probably forget probably like tonight or
monday because yeah people are asking we
gotta get ready shout out to the clan
king's fall looked like it was leaked so
friday's y'all know what to do we got
some good uh world's first raid day
situation salute to all the people in
the class you know what you call it in
there too buddha that was in there
earlier so so that's all the clan
members in there
i got to do the race
going to be on fortnight so you can stop
capping i might have to join y'all
because it doesn't we going today
yeah i might have to join because i i
need to try to know build more otherwise
citizens oh it's mad dope yeah and i
don't even try something just to see i
heard it's right
was playing with bill in them right and
he said it was fire he said he liked it
i got to try it i can't i can't slather
the game and i didn't try this game
on your back
are we good we good caught up yep
right lloyd addict where can the fine
people find you not being messy and
debating you can find me on twitter at
lord adam ilp you can find me on
youtube at gaming addict uh you know we
we do have some stuff
in the works for you guys
um i don't know if we're going to be
reacting to the
the yeah still in the thing flux on that
yeah we're still on the flux on that
game
it depends what time is that to it it's
against time it's tuesday i know is it
destiny's launch reaction tuesday thing
there's so much going on we got to
figure it out behind the scenes
uh so
definitely be looking out for that i
don't know what's going to happen as of
right now
um you know we got we got real life
stuff going on but we will definitely
get to you guys uh the moment we can and
i appreciate it we had we had to like i
think
700 and something yeah it was a good
show man we had a lot of people come
through you guys can show up every week
really appreciate that
and until next week you know uh people
who play on pc you know you should
restate your life oh hold on
someone coming for king neck
shout out to splendiferous you saw that
song
he put the whole video up yeah just add
me you ain't gotta do all this you ain't
gotta talk you gotta shout out you don't
gotta bring a crowd to your beatdown
you want to smoke king yeah well just
add me i sat there and i waited splendid
it's king david otw put it there
oh you're trying to say oh oh oh you
gave him the location i told you the
location of your soul you said you'll
pull up and i'm saying yo where
then you know the hands is a feeling
shout out to him time time for that but
i was funny that was funny no doubt
continue also i'm addict that was it
yeah that's pretty much it i i am gonna
be
making some adjustments to my youtube
channel um you know in case you guys
notice i don't really put a whole lot of
content on there anymore
um i think i'm going to take that
channel a different direction uh i've
been i've been enjoying the the
non-content life and i think i'm going
to keep it that way
i would say
do a vlog right and you can do what in
the wonderful world of attic is going on
today
just actually have yourself walking
around recording wild stuff that you do
like when you was getting your hair cut
you could have sat there and actually
recorded that and just posted a joint
right there
and you can actually probably go
straight into the addict's world
whatever he said i'm probably going to
strip
i mean i'm not doing that vlogging like
what's too crazy
like like like what what what hair
products he used like what did you eat
for breakfast when you sit down you
could bowl a cereal i ate a piece of
toast for breakfast i'm done and we want
to know what fahrenheit was it
does addict like dark toast does he like
light toast what is addict into what
type of bread like you know is it wonder
time
i'm pretty sure it's i'm pretty sure
it's dollar store brand see we we want
to know what addict's putting in his
body
anyway
and uh so
how are you doing sir what's going on yo
good good uh look out for uh lord's
minute later on uh this week lady uh
lady uh lyric and i will be talking
about uh
a certain game coming to gamepad
i wonder which
we absolutely did not discuss here today
um so we're talking about that uh yeah
and then next week so i i'm having
surgery on wednesday so but i i will be
here sunday
in another capacity i'll be here yes
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
you know you never know
concerned about these things nah i know
what it is is he going there and they
changed his vocal cords and he started
coming out talking like james jones
i am your father i heard your father
i agree yeah but you know it's funny
because i told wifey the other day i was
like hey you know i got to show you all
these passwords and this that and the
other she's like
no you're not no you died we ain't doing
that she's like we are not doing that
you better take him now
he's like
it's fine i'll just make new accounts
i don't worry about it
i have them already don't worry about it
yeah
but that's
[Laughter]
yeah so i'll see y'all next week
definitely well if you feel up to it
we'll see don't worry mm-hmm anyway we
have video uh-huh some of this stuff
going down ridiculous
and the king where can we find you
what's going on find me on uh on twitter
drinking sony tears
you know i have pure confidence
in
in the ability of sony's to fail every
week and give me content that is
undeniably the funniest thing on the
internet
yo i'm going next week most likely
you'll have it too hell yeah they've
been doing it every week without fail
jim hits me up and say
hold my bed check this out
you can't be serious jim
on twitter king david otw splint
difference it's the same damn name you
tweeting at
the same name
two dollar super chess for difference
when i got on it said you was offline
i'm always awkward and sinister said you
camping too he said he said you uh
you saw i send you the picture i saw you
seeing it so you can stop it right now
so i'm trying to pile in and be with
somebody else
and you take your lumps separate
then we got spartan go 17 yeah on king
side two pounds super chat told him to
pull up a splendiferous folded oh damn
damn
see see splint your name is not you know
real strong in these streets
you put up a whole video oh yeah he did
hit it right at you with my name tag and
you said i was offline that means send
me a message
if you were to send the invite all you
the soul's hands come out your screen
and i would have just got it
with you and then you would have just
been like i'm sorry sir i'm gonna
invite you into this room translation
translation send the message just now
that's it as soon as i get out of here
you see me someplace else and then as
soon as you press that button understand
like like steven they said
do not press send
so difference ain't no folding over here
except by adding okay okay okay
no doubt
that's about it you can catch me on uh
fortnight playing that uh this week uh
i'm gonna have a fun-filled week uh i
got the youngest with me so we gonna
have a whole bunch of fun no bunch of
fun but also it's gamescom this week so
look out for what we're trying to do
uh also
the lord's minute uh this week what
wouldn't it's not going to be up it's
going to be up next week we're going to
be talking about she-hulk
that first episode which i found to be
used
yeah i'm so bad oh and house of dragons
tonight oh it's tonight yes
tonight that's great i gotta check that
out again shout out to everybody just
real quick if casey i didn't know
um got that starter kit you know what
i'm saying for that new powder you know
what i'm saying get that advanced gg go
get that so those who want commit you
know they don't want to get the all big
expensive full bottle drink get yourself
a little joint use coal iron iron lord
on the checkout go check that out a
little 10 bucks you know what i'm saying
go get that got a couple of my favorite
flavors in there so shout out to the
partnership with advanced gg they
stopped pedaling
yeah that was funny that was funny
playing listen i'm moving my powder
right now let me do my thing you don't
get 30 this month dj listen this starter
kit get the energy flavors the favorite
choice that you like go get that
advanced gg links in the chat also you
already know on the merch side i see
y'all with the stop sticking shirts i
see y'all with the show with your build
shirts we got the the slides in there go
check that out it's in the description
as well embedded on the actual
yo they said pushing that phone yo y'all
stupid listen i'm pushing boo i'm making
moves out here let me make my let me
bust a move all right anyway that's what
i got next sunday should be fun we got
some more fun things lined up in the
future and then also gamescom
man yeah shout out to brad sims the
legend finally we had that habit that
was long time in the making and he gave
us some good premium bars and some time
like i said gamescom and then we got to
talk about pax west we'll talk offline
how that's going to go anyway catch
y'all up that's all i got anybody
anything else we good no all right we
out of here see y'all next
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so